want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you two you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best belief life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
dean graziosi enjoy
who could you be doing this for when you
want to get up and work out when you
want to take the run when you want to
just take a walk when you want to say no
to the unhealthy food you know when your
friends are like oh stop eating like a
bird stop eating like a cow eat some
real meat eat some food or whatever it
is
it's easy to go you know they're
probably right i deserve it i work hard
where do you go now
i'm doing this for my wife i'm doing
this for my husband doing this for my
kids doing this for me i'm doing this
for my 70 year old self you know it's
really hard to teach kids to do better
things now so they don't get sick at 50
60 70. really hard they can't see that
far in advance but i talk to my kids
like this all the time and i know it
sinks in at some level it's like
do this for your 60 year old self
you want to feel great i mean i have
some dear friends i went to high school
with i love them to death but 51 hasn't
treated them so well
right 51 hasn't treated them so well and
this is not like i do i pray for them
but i remember when i used to make the
harder choices you know i always say
live the hard way now for an easier life
later or live an easy life now for
harder later i can remember times with
some of my the exact friends when i make
healthier choices or different choices
or go to the gym after a night of going
out with them and get home at two
o'clock and at six o'clock i'm at the
gym like you're crazy
who's crazy like now they're like i
literally have one friend who's like why
didn't i listen to you he's going
through a really tough time health-wise
right same age as me
harder now to live a better life in the
future so who would you do that for so
find a who
and think about them when you feel like
eating wrong or making bad choices or
not go in the gym who would you do it
for enthusiasm will always outweigh
perfection
and preparation
i told you all that stuff about the
things i'm not so good at for a reason
because i got through life the first
part especially by being enthusiastic
my enthusiasm outweighed that i'm not
that intelligent that i don't have an i
great iq all i know is there's so many
people that will obsess on making sure
everything's perfect before they engage
making sure everything is prepared
perfectly and years go by
you're much better off getting
enthusiasm and jumping in the game and
learning as you go jump out of the plane
and hope the shoot opens on the way down
hope most time it does
you can't score a touchdown being on the
sidelines but you sure can if you're in
the game so i want you guys to give
yourselves a break right now because
some of you if it is realist that you
haven't made your first deal you haven't
talked to a seller or a buyer yet
because you're thinking maybe i'm not an
expert yet i need to get a little more
prepared i need a little more time under
my belt
with that get in the game get
enthusiastic get enthusiasm and just
take action action creates momentum
knowledge without action is just good
reading like we said before
and when you find enthusiasm
let me just back up so where do you find
enthusiasm and here's what i say is i
borrow mine from the past
when i want to be enthusiastic i look
backwards on times that i was scared and
still did it on times when i thought it
was going to go wrong but i made it
happen on times where i had incredible
accomplishments and times where i felt
amazing felt alive it could be something
completely different it could be a first
relationship it could be anything that
lights you up and borrow that enthusiasm
and put it in today's time because what
it does is it also changes
your state of mind
because here's what i know when your
enthusiasm is down when you're thinking
about everything being perfect when
you're thinking about one step at a time
are you in the right space to take
action
when your confidence is down do you take
action
or do you say how about when your
confidence is down just a little bit and
you watch the news or you get a friend
tell you oh stop dreaming or the economy
is going to crash or the market's going
to crash if your confidence is down and
your enthusiasm is down how does that
hit you compared to when you feel on
fire
right when you're when you're down and
your your confidence is just 10 off you
go well yeah maybe things are good
enough the way they are
maybe i'll just leave it where it is
with that borrow the enthusiasm from the
past and attack each day and it starts
with you being completely honest with
yourself
on where you are right now in history
where are you after covet
where are you that the world has changed
where are you with your confidence where
are you with your income where are you
with your career
where are you with your happiness around
those things where are you with your
relationship
where are you with your health your
connection to a higher power
there's lots of things we can use this
tool for to get complete honestly get
completely honest because let's just say
it like it is
all change starts when you're brutally
honest that you're disturbed by standing
still you're disturbed by inaction
think about it that's how we move that's
how the rocket gets off the ground is
being disturbed with leaving your life
the way it is so unfortunately you're
like oh now i'm listening to this
podcast and i'm gonna get disturbed yes
because if you're agitated you move
right
so let's pick your career your income
what you do for a living
where are you with that
are you happy with your career are you
happy with the business that you started
are you happy that
you started the business but it's not
really going where you want
listen we all make decisions for one of
two reasons we're either moving away
from something painful or we want to
move towards something pleasurable right
we either have to get out of this job or
we lost our job or it's just toxic or
it's not making me the money i have to
move or it's okay it's not bad but you
know you have another level you know god
designed way more for you than you're
doing
and the inaction of either one of those
should disturb you either away from the
pain or towards the pleasure so
at any time you could stop and write
this down or come back at another time
or type it in your phone if you're being
completely honest about your income your
career
what you do for a living starting the
business or not any of those
if you're completely honest where are
you because all change starts with a
starting point right all directions on
your gps you need the starting point
where are you as the starting point now
that the world has shifted sometimes you
know things like cove would pull back
the curtain and made us make us really
analyze our lives and we don't want to
go back to who we used to be i get it i
see it every day okay the next thing if
you know where you are now
then we have to decide where do you want
to go now
right now where do you want to go that
sounds like an obvious question i want
more success i want more happiness i
want more joy if it's not defined if
it's fuzzy fuzzy targets don't get hit
we need a definitive plan we need to
know exactly what our compelling future
is we need that lighthouse to drive
towards and what is that for you
most people know what they don't want
that's just a true story most people
know what they don't want they're
avoiding potholes they're driving away
from problems but they're not driving
towards where they want to go if you and
i jumped in an elevator together and i
said hey it's a year from now and it was
the best year of your life what's that
look like where do you want to go
would you be able to literally in four
or five sentences tell me where it is
you want and where you want to go or
would you go wow good question dean let
me think about it because that's what 90
of the people say i've been asking
people for over a decade good question
let me think about it
how do you know how can you get to where
you want to go if you don't have your
gps on where it is you want to be
what i never understood
is
when you were in high school or college
or just starting out life you have these
dreams you have the aspirations you have
this you have these big goals in some
cases right and the world tells us that
we're dreaming i mean think about when
we want to step out from the line
everybody else is having and go after
our own
and do our own thing and people saying
hey get real uh when you get a lola
you'll see that that's not and all of a
sudden you start squashing your dreams
you start playing smaller in your own
life to make people around you feel
better and here's the thing you quit
your dream you quit your desire and you
take some job that makes somebody else
happy and all of a sudden you get
somebody's arm around you saying hey
now you're finally growing up really
what if you just decided today
that you are gonna whatever it is you're
currently doing it you're gonna find it
to be fun you're gonna do it to the best
of your ability because it's only
temporary it's only part of your journey
it was designed for you so you could
know where you really want to go when i
see people say i just hate this i'm just
going to get by till this comes along
what's going to come along think about
that
is everybody become successful
no only the ones who go after it so you
got the knowledge you got the wisdom
you're surrounding yourself with with
information that has been proven to work
so what's left
it's taking action
that's the formula knowledge plus action
equals results what i'd love for you to
do today is an action audit
are you really putting into play what
you are learning are you just dabbling
are you over preparing causing you to be
crippled that you're not taking action
and start using whatever it takes
to ethically bribe yourself to take
action listen today
i didn't want to get up
simple going to the gym at 5 30 my alarm
went off at five i really didn't want to
go i'm tired you hear my voice you never
hear my voice have a little tiredness
since i've been on the move i've been in
a plane every day i've been teaching
every day talking every day but what i
did is i i hacked my own brain i said if
i don't go work out today
how will that make you feel i didn't
work out yesterday morning i had to get
up at five o'clock and jump on a plane
so you didn't work out yesterday you're
not going to work out today how that
make you feel when you play with your
kids later what if you're tired when you
when you put your pants on there's a
little muffin top on your pants it
doesn't matter what it is i just use
whatever it takes to get me to take
action if it's you saying hey in five
years from now i'm still gonna be at
this job i'm still gonna be stressed i'm
still gonna have these bills i'm still
not gonna live the life i want i still
can't retire my parents or take care of
my kids or put money away in savings or
buy the car i want or have the freedom i
want whatever it takes get disturbed
because if you get disturbed
it'll cause action or if the opposite be
to serve say if i do this i get to dream
i get to get the house i get the life i
get more freedom i get more control in
life all i'm saying is use whatever it
takes in your toolbox whether it's being
disturbed or whether it's getting
excited to take action because knowledge
listening to me listening to books going
to masterminds without implementing it
is just wasting your time i wish someone
would have pounded into my brain week
after week after week that it's not the
end game it's not the magic money
machine it's not the invention you come
up with success starts at your core
success starts with the right habits
with the right principles with the right
values everybody's trying to plug in the
get rich quick schemes on top of the
wrong
foundation on top of the wrong rules and
then you wonder why you go from
opportunity to opportunity and you never
go deep you never make the money you
never become a millionaire be careful
never become financially independent
i will scream from the mountaintops
maybe it's my age maybe it's the success
i've i've been blessed to have but i
obsess on looking backwards
understanding what got me here it wasn't
cars when i was in high school it wasn't
cutting firewood when i was in early
high school it wasn't
real estate it wasn't
building houses or renting houses or
flipping houses yes that was the end
result writing books creating courses
doing live events yes that was the end
result to massive success in my life
blessed beyond belief
but if i go upstream
if i really look at what got me here
what powered through unsupportive
parents or friends or not having money
and not having a college education not
feeling that smart not having the
confidence in some cases had nothing to
do with those
it had to do with the principles if you
really look at the people who evolve who
reach their full potential who are at
the next level some people might say
they admire them or even have envy for
them it's those
who can handle the failures they can
they can handle when things go wrong i
remember reading many years ago an
article about sarah blakely the founder
of spanx and how she had multiple
failures before spanx in fact i think
even a bankruptcy don't quote me on that
but when the reporter was asking her how
did you handle those terrible failures
those those those things that went wrong
and still be able to rebound in my
opinion reading the story she was almost
like dumbfounded that he would ask such
a silly question when she replied and
said that growing up her dad would ask
her multiple times during the week in
fact even maybe even once a day what she
failed at today and if she said nothing
then he would say well then you
obviously didn't push yourself far
enough you were obviously playing it
safe people fail when they push to the
limits and what happened was she changed
what failure meant to her at a really
early age she realized which most every
successful person does that failure
is the building blocks to your success
failure must occur in order to reach
your next level get really disturbed
because when we're disturbed we move
you stand on hot pavement what do you do
do you stand there go wow this hurts you
know you run your ass off to get off the
hot pavement because you're disturbed
because it's painful let the pain sink
in get disturbed within action and take
uncomfortable
imperfect action today not next week
not when it feels right
now
if someone would have told me in my 20s
maybe even in my 30s that being a part
of a group or being a part of a
mastermind where everybody's getting
smarter is the fastest way to your next
level i would have said whatever i don't
even know what that is i don't
understand it the only way i can learn
is by getting out there and doing it
through my own trial and error and
wasn't i a fool
listen you are here because you want
another level of success and if i wasn't
completely transparent with you if i
didn't open your mind up to new ways to
gain knowledge wisdom and capabilities
if i didn't share
my own stories my own evolution that i'd
be doing a massive disservice to you i'm
going to let you in on a little secret
i did not read one book in my 20s not
one i had dyslexia in school when i
tried to read i was so embarrassed it
kind of it pushed me away from reading i
thought reading was bad and here's the
thing i made massive gains in my 20s i
went from completely broke no money
credit card debt uh no college education
to being a millionaire in my 20s
documented or else i i wouldn't share it
here and i did that by my own trial and
error i did it by massive amounts of
failure massive amounts of doing it
wrong massive amounts of stress
insane amounts of time
obsessing and worrying and thinking and
losing sleep over yes i powered my way
through it i had grit
but what i wasn't smart enough to
realize and what i want to share with
you is i was a fool
contrary to that i have a 18 year old
kid that works for me his name is ryan
that i mentor and i teach and he's a
part of masterminds and he is gaining
the collective wisdom of people who have
already experienced what he wants to do
so if i was going to boil down what a
mastermind is a mastermind is different
than a live event where someone is at
the front of the room pitching to you or
sharing with you or teaching you i've
been to countless live events they're
amazing they're game changers but a
mastermind is a is a brainstorm a
mastermind is think of collective wisdom
in a room so
let's say you wanted to learn how to
write a book and sell it
on social media now you can look at all
the other ads read books about it go out
write your book and try to sell it
amazing much better than just writing it
and guessing it if you model other
people wonderful if you read a book on
it wonderful
how much better would that be if you
went to a live event and someone was up
on stage and they gave a 60-minute
presentation on how they took an idea in
their head
and then turned it into a book and then
turned it into marketing and sold a lot
that's another level right pages and
pages and notes
but now let's talk about a mastermind
what if you were in a mastermind with 20
other people who have already
written books that were successful
on social media and you got to be in
that collective wisdom and that
collective
consciousness of success meaning you get
to learn from each of their when i say
collective you could say have one person
say wow it took me about a year to write
the book and someone said oh my god i
know it used to take me a year to write
a book but here's what i do i get my
phone out and i just go through the
voice memo and i come up with chapter
heads
and then when i'm in the mood even when
i'm in the car driving i just hit record
and i record the whole chapter and then
i take it and i forward it to rev
they're a transcription service that's
really cheap really inexpensive and they
have it back in like five hours then
when that gets back i just edit my own
words and oh my god i had a chapter done
so i did that 12 times i had my 12
chapters and the book was done
and you're like oh my god that just
saved me a year okay give me that
information on how to write it and then
someone else goes yeah i did something
similar when i got my book done took me
about six months to get momentum to sell
it on on facebook and someone else goes
oh wait a minute when i got done i
thought the same thing but what i did is
i started making one minute hook videos
on instagram and what i did is in those
one minutes i would deliver a massive
amount of value in the beginning i'd say
hey here's a secret that you need if you
want to lose weight go faster make more
money be healthier have a better
relationship here's one secret hey if
you'd like more of those secrets click
the link on this page and get my book
and you go wow you how many books did
you sell on instagram like that with
those one minute power messages 10 000.
oh my god can i have that idea yes now
i'm exaggerating here but do you see
how masterminding how brainstorming with
the collective wisdom in the room all of
a sudden you get years and years and
years of experience
all by the people who have been there or
done or even
failed at what you want here's the
greatest thing about being around people
when they go yeah i'm going to write
this book and i'm going to sell it for
25 on facebook somebody says um
i tried on facebook for 25. for some
reason you can't get momentum i try to
every way to sunday got the best
marketing people on the planet but
here's what i did learn if you sell it
for under 19
and then you have a customer funnel you
over deliver so much on the book that
people come back and buy more products
from you it's okay to lose money on the
front because
they'll love you because you wrote such
a good book they'll come back and buy
more of your products and you'll still
be more cash flow positive and you can
impact the world get your book out to
people instead of trying to ask so much
on the front that might have taken him
five years or her five years to figure
out you know how quick you get it just
like that so why am i obsessing on this
for you because i wish someone would
have told me the power of masterminding
if we can shift and realize that the
definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing our
enthusiasm then all of a sudden we just
want to fail as fast as we can to get it
out of the way and here's what i believe
i believe with all of me and i share
this a lot because it's so important is
that we all have to pay success tax and
the tax is the failures and overcoming
them we have to pretend there's an
auditor up in the space and sky in
heaven whatever you want to believe and
they're watching our failures they
watched my daughter fail at that game
she's only going to get good when they
go yup check she had that bad game she
didn't give up uh check she wanted to
come out of the game she wouldn't lend
she didn't argue with her coach check
check check check and then success
follows if you want to
if you want to play in a band you would
you would be so excited to be able to
play in front of 50 000 people a pack
stadium all singing your songs jamming
in front of everybody but you don't get
to do that unless you work hard when no
one's watching you get everybody
watching in eyeballs to win the game or
play the concert or make the money that
only happens because you play when no
one's watching and usually you fail
miserably you have to pay the success
tax you have to if you're out there
jamming in front of 50 000 people i'd
bet to say you showed up at a gig many
times where no one showed up absolute
failure but you still got up the next
day and practice
same thing in your life
we want more money we want more freedom
we want more choices but most people
aren't aren't willing to go through the
failures aren't willing to take that
research and development
that knowledge that we get from failures
learn what not to do what to do let the
rest pass and then continue with
enthusiasm to your next venture the
quote for me that makes the biggest
impact the definition of success by
winston churchill is going from failure
to failure without losing your
enthusiasm that's the definition of life
know that those failures are just
fine-tuning your acts they're sharpening
your pick they're allowing you to go
faster and quicker by learning from your
mistakes and learning what's right and
the most successful people i know know
how to rebound fast learn from those
experiences and keep pushing forward
transform heartbreak
into your leverage
so as an underdog
your parents or your friends
may not have faith in you or support you
and that's heartbreaking
did you ever have a just like you
watched me one day you read my book or
somebody else or you saw something
online or you got involved in my real
estate course and you're like damn i'm
doing this and you're you're you're
using the power of you can't you don't
even know you are you're
you're you're being innovative you're
enthusiastic and you go tell the person
you care about the most
and they shut you down like a lid just
like like shutting off a light switch
like oh that's so dumb this is the wrong
time you don't have the money
and they shut you down
that's heartbreaking
also
i've watched
so many people when they have a desire
for more if you're watching me you're
someone who's working on your personal
growth you're working on your success
you want another level of life you
realize one of the biggest plights of
our world is living knowing you have
untapped potential it's the worst
feeling in the world you know you got
more gas in the tank but you're not
putting the throttle down because people
are telling you and you can't i just
told my daughter i stole this from sean
stevenson my three-foot giant my dear
friend he said don't anyone don't ever
let anyone dim your glow so you can
match them you're bright be like nah nah
nah and a lot of times we turn down our
lights so we can match that screw that
brighten yours up more have you ever
been in a relationship
it could be family friends partnership
or significant other you're in a
relationship you because you're here
there's a million other things you can
be doing you're here with me you're
working on your personal growth you are
your success abundance you want to tap
into that next level not leave it don't
die at 98 years old and go wow i had a
lot more to give the world but i didn't
oh my god did you feel that screw that i
want to be like nothing left i'm done
time to go nothing left but think about
this you're working on your personal
growth you start with somebody here
they are at this level but they decide
this is a perfect level for them
and all of a sudden you're continuing to
work on your personal growth and you're
going higher and you're going higher and
now they're saying oh stop you're
getting all fufu oh you're two oh my god
what are you gonna go to tony robbins
event and jump up and down you're gonna
go to a dean graziosi growth event and
blah blah blah and all of a sudden
you're going and all going and going and
you get to a point and they're like oh
my god we've grown apart
and somebody leaves you or someone calls
you tells you that you're a dreamer or
you know good i've watched it happen so
many times with people who desire
another level of life because the people
around you want to stay status quo and
you make them uncomfortable so
heartbreak is pretty high in this world
in this world of growing of going next
level that's okay because that's the way
it's supposed to be i believe god the
universe would have really designed it
that way because they're meant to be
with these people and you're meant to be
with us
it doesn't mean you have to hurt anybody
along the way but there's a lot of
heartache there's a lot of heartbreak so
what i notice with underdogs who spin it
into a win is they take that heartbreak
from any area from parents from a
relationship from a marriage to a bad
partnership they take that heartbreak
and they ball it back up poof and use it
as energy you have a dream you have a
desire and when you're a certain age you
stop that dream maybe you got serious
about a job and people put their arm
around you and said you're finally
growing up i appreciate your
responsibility really
i just threw my dreams in the toilet and
you want to say you're proud of me but
it anchored that in oh that's the right
thing my parents my friends my teachers
one more time screw that
they did it because they thought they
were caring and loving you and that's
not it
you have to push past the fear listen
i don't i don't like to always use me as
an example let me just share matt larson
my top real estate students didn't go to
college got actually got thrown out of
college tried one semester they threw
him out didn't have any money grew up on
a farm
that not his farm his father managed
another farm in a little tiny rented
place worked on a farm went to be a
machine shop worker worked 70 hours a
week in a machine shop
lived in a 300 square foot apartment
did all the stuff i'm telling you got my
courses spent a lot of money on his
education and his family came to him and
said are you crazy real estate's for
rich people you'll never be able to do
it his girlfriend broke up with him
because he spent lots of money on the
education said you're a dreamer and he
was re he called us to literally give
everything back and we said did you even
try he's like no but
but all stories all fear all we said is
please go try it
that was like 3 500
real estate deals ago millions of
dollars generated lives change he's a
partner of mine he's a great dude he
went to a whole nother level he employs
70 people
do you know what almost killed him was
the fear of believing all the
lack of better word he was told all
those years it wasn't the real estate
skills it wasn't the real estate market
it didn't mean that he wasn't because he
didn't go to college and he didn't have
money or was he was in too small of a
town or too big of a city or too hot of
a market or there's no good deals or
banded signs don't work had nothing to
do with that he almost quit because of
the fear of breaking through of
listening to all the crap
what about you
anything like that close ever happened
to you
of course it has you might be thinking
it right now dean you want me to write
down what i'm good at you want me to
write down what i like to do that's not
going to make me money that's not true
completely not true i i was i had
dyslexia i barely got out of high school
i was a car mechanic in my 20s every day
greasy hands and painting cars and
sucking in fumes if somebody would have
said yeah that car mechanic in there
that's all dirty with his
mechanic outfit on he's going to write
multiple new york times best-selling
books he's going to be best friends with
tony robbins and richard branson he's
going to touch the lives of millions of
people
and say that guy no wait a minute you're
talking that guy over there the one
sucking paint fumes paint inside the car
never
right
so don't tell me wherever you are you
can't go to where you want to go i'm
giving you the keys i'm giving you the
principles i wish i wish i wish i wish
someone would have told me this stuff
earlier on it doesn't matter if you're
20 40 60 80 or 90
today's the day you could start today's
the day you could break through that
fear today's the day you can realize
what my vision is and how i can start
saying no to stuff so i can work on my
unique ability so i can go to that next
level don't get consumed by the busy
work don't lie to yourself everyone
right here come on look in my eyes stop
lying to yourself we all do i'm not
calling you out without calling myself
out i lie to myself
i was busy i had to do this and then do
that all it was is my subconscious doing
busy work so i didn't have to dig into
the hard work that actually moves the
needle and can take me to a place of
solution resolution and next level
so really identify what are you doing
that's busy work and what are you doing
that can actually move the needle to
make you a better version of you to
create new revenue to get the company
going to anchor in new success habits
that actually shift your thinking so you
can focus on what's right how do you
become the role model how do you become
the leader that's
that's how you get your butt off the
couch that's how you stop
procrastinating falling back into those
beliefs
one thing and i didn't
i didn't have this strategy then
but now that i look back what happened
is when i started to narrow it down and
this is the part i want all of you to
hear as you narrow down your niche and
what you're going to teach your
confidence goes up and your ability for
success goes up we think bigger is
better it's not in this case the smaller
the better the smaller the niche the
smaller the thing you're going to teach
your confidence will explode and the
ability to impact the exact people
is so much greater right so what i was
thinking is seven billion people that
seems overwhelming
but then
i said well you know for what i was
teaching i could only teach people in
america so that gets a lot smaller okay
so now it's not 7 billion people it's
300 million people in america but i
don't want to teach everybody in america
i only want to teach people that
want to be in the car business maybe
that gets way smaller it's like not the
car business because what i thought
about
i can't teach anybody with a new car
dealership i don't know how to do the
financing and work with ford or general
motors or honda i don't know any of that
oh my god that's people way over my head
way different so it's not just people in
america and the car dealership it's the
used car industry
so i want to help people in the used car
industry but then i started thinking
it's like i i can't help people it's got
that have like 10 dealerships or have
sold thousands of cars that's not me i'd
be a phony i can't teach that
i just want to teach people
how to sell used cars and just do a few
to supplement their income and all of a
sudden it's getting smaller and i
started thinking okay i can do that i
could teach the first person somebody to
do their first car maybe do one a month
and supplement their income because i
know how to do this but then i realized
when i was really broke and didn't have
money i came up with one unique strategy
that really helped my life that took the
niche all the way down this little tiny
dot
it was that dot right there so i went
from seven billion people to people in
america to the car industry to the used
car industry all the way down to the
tiny dot of just helping people make a
little bit of extra money by using this
strategy to flip cars and subscribe and
when i did
oh my god when i did everything changed
when i did that my confidence went
through the roof
when i did that i didn't feel like i was
an imposter anymore
i knew that if i had new people in a
room if i could get people to read my
course they just want to make a little
extra money who weren't in the car
business not in the new car business oh
my god then i sat down every morning and
i was writing for that person you guys
feel that i was talking to that person i
was writing headlines for that person i
was creating chapters and exercise for
the new person if someone was in the car
business for 20 years they probably
would have laughed at my course but
that's not who i marketed to
and when i did here's the crazy part i
got done with the course i was obsessing
on the logos and the pieces and i did i
had to do an infomercial
and the crazy part is i had no clue i
had no money i didn't know where to
start
um
but that infomercial shifted my life all
of those things were happening
but when i narrowed it down when i knew
tony robbins served and shifted my life
when i knew there was people out there
that could do a few cars a month or one
a month or a few years to supplement
life i knew i must i want you to look at
things this way because there's two ways
to look at this unique ability circle
is as entrepreneurs consider yourself an
entrepreneur or not you're somebody
seeking another level john baptiste in
1790 coined the frame frames uh
entrepreneur by saying someone who takes
one level of productivity to another you
want to take your income your life your
health your happiness your joy to
another level to me entrepreneur i think
i think sometimes that's
in today's world for some reason it
gives it a bad name okay that's why
sometimes you feel lonely it's like no i
don't want to do what everybody else
does i want to go after my dreams my
goals i want to be in control of my life
that's a bad thing then i'll be on the
bad list
but here's what dan sullivan how he
teaches us as entrepreneurs as success
seekers we've said yes to everything to
get here so we say yes to the things we
suck at we say things that we're okay at
that we're good at excellent at and
sometimes we spend some time in our
unique ability in your unique ability
you make a thousand dollars an hour
is that possible of course it is i'm
gonna use real estate as an example any
unique ability if it's finding deals
other people can't and then finding
buyers
buyers are easy to find but finding
deals and you find a wholesale deal that
takes you five hours total and you make
five grand could you make a thousand
bucks an hour absolutely so let me just
use that as a realistic number that's in
real estate doesn't matter what you're
doing what business you're in let's you
know and if you're working for someone
else making a thousand bucks an hour
might be an impossible thing i know that
i'm just using this for reference but
think about what you do for a living
what you're good at what you like what
could cut you the biggest check if you
were just focused in that when i'm
writing a book with as many books as it
sell when i'm writing my books i know
i'm making a thousand bucks an hour or
whatever that number is right so let's
just say in your unique ability make a
thousand bucks an hour and and this the
things you suck at
don't make you anything but let's just
say ten dollars an hour
okay so for me
writing teaching educating flipping real
estate
creating a new information
product those things that's where i'm in
my unique ability when i'm training with
you right now this fires me up gives me
enthusiasm that's what i love to do
uh down here
trying to edit my own slides trying to
edit my book i write a long email and i
try to edit it and i'm doing this i'm
wasting my time trying to create an
excel spreadsheet trying to work on
technology trying to figure out
everything on my cell phone i don't know
at all i i get one of my assistants to
show me how to do things set up siri at
my house so i can listen to music it
overwhelms me i get like uh
i used to think i should know that i
should be smarter now it's like nope i'm
not gonna
i have a house concierge this sounds
like i'm bragging but what i've come to
realize if i work in my unique ability
everything below this becomes an roi a
return on investment so let's just say
this is a hundred dollars an hour or a
day or whatever the number is right
let's just say it's a hundred dollars an
hour or five dollar twenty dollars an
hour hundred you know whatever the
number is here for you but let's just
say things you suck at is ten let's just
say this is twenty let's just say this
is forty dollars an hour let's say the
things you're excellent or fifty
or a hundred dollars an hour you could
be making what dan's whole point is and
you can look at this in different many
different ways lowering complexity or
whatever dan's whole thing is when you
peel the onion back and you get to where
you can live in here what you're good at
or you like
and the biggest check
right the biggest check
all of these become an roi why would you
do stuff at 10 bucks an hour when you
can live here and pay that person or why
would you even do stuff you're good at
or excellent at or excellent at when it
becomes an roi and i want you this is
not anything that's going to happen
today i'm not saying you're going to do
this today but i want you to think about
this because most people don't
entrepreneurs are lonely entrepreneurs
think differently than everybody we make
money different than today we are you're
sitting here watching me there's a
million other things you could be doing
this morning some of you might be at
work sneaking this i know it's the
middle of the day
but you're here you do things different
than everybody you got to start thinking
differently this isn't corporate
structure this isn't trying to evolve
through the ranks this is thinking in a
creative way outside the box tap into
unique ability tap into your own
enthusiasm and authenticity and think a
little bit differently than everyone
else would you care if your friends went
to the movies and they didn't invite you
would you care if someone was rude to
you would you care if someone cut you
off in traffic
how would you be to people around you if
it was rainy would you say it's a rainy
day or would you say oh my god look at
the abundance of this amazing rain
if a mosquito bit you would it bug you
if you had a week left to live like oh
my god that little thing just kicked my
ass
and then i think about this is from the
untethered soul if if
a higher power whoever you believe in
god came down and spent time with you do
you want to be the person
that lets all those little things bug
you the let's gets the angst gets the
gets in you know suffers or would you
want to be the person that just is in a
living an abundant mindset an abundant
life and i would love for you guys to
take a few moments and not think of the
bucket list stuff
but think of the things you would change
immediately what would you do
if a really
sweet pleasant angel came down to
deliver you the bad news that you had a
week left to live
i think so much would change i mean
there might be some bucket list stuff
but i know throughout a day when i when
i think through that framing
nothing gets me off especially in the
last six months nothing gets me off
track nothing gets me to be angst and
and i have to tell you i i was always
high energy i was always running away
from my past and being homeless as a kid
and couldn't read well and getting made
fun of like i was always running from
that i always felt i had to run 100
miles an hour and i had to work all
night and i could take on the stress
something goes wrong with the business
give it to me something's wrong there's
a conflict give it to me i'll fix it
give it to me and i'd hold it and i'd
still i'd walk around with a smile on
the outside but i knew there was this
burning hole of anxiety and stress and
worry about going backwards and i
thought for so many years that was my
driving force i don't want to go
backwards i'm scared i don't i have this
anxiety but i can power through and once
i let that go i i was afraid to let it
go thinking that was my power that was
my superhero that was that's what drove
me and it was a lie
you can accomplish just as much with
zero suffering think of
what we do in life as mapping out new
terrain right so think of the think of
our life as like the earth and we're
explorers right and some people take one
path they go to work every day they do
the same thing same couple of friends
they do and that's and they're okay with
this one straight line path they don't
see any of the world they just they do
this they go do their thing and they
come back that's one version
and there's some people
who say this this path that everybody
says is great this path that everybody
like says this is the security this is
the safety this is how life is supposed
to be it's like screw that and they
wander off the path right if you're here
with us today you're here with me today
you're part of the inner circle um
that means that you're someone who's
wandered off the path congratulations
the path sucks the path is what
everybody else does the path that and if
you're if somebody's on it and they're
miserable they want you to be on the
path with them when they see you strain
like no no get back on here it's not
safe out there no it's not safe on the
path
we have one life we got to squeeze every
bit of juice out of this life you don't
want to look back at the end of your
life being 100 years old be in the
hospital go wow i walk the same path
every day i'm so glad i played it safe
no screw that no one says that [ __ ] then
you're like why didn't i step off the
path why didn't i go for more why didn't
i tap into my why didn't i go after
being an artist go after real estate
investing go after doing my own online
business go out to the fitness world go
in the coaching world go sing why why
didn't i do it because someone told you
staying on the path was smart screw that
get off the path
but if you think about that and you're
mapping out terrain so just think if
we're explorers if we're on the path
we get to explore a new territory i'm
going to read some of these guys
we get to explore new
territory but when you explore new
territory you've kind of mapped out that
terrain now if you go off the path and
you find a cliff you can mark that if
you find paradise you could mark that if
you find water you mark that you find
mountains you mark that you find the
ocean you mark it and all of a sudden
you start exploring for me going through
this process i mapped out a whole new
bunch of terrain i'm not that i'm not
listen can i tell you something i feel
absolutely positively
bulletproof
because i face the biggest fear of my
life there's nothing that can get me let
me just tell you something i drive down
the road and somebody cuts me off i wave
to them i order chicken for dinner they
bring me steak well done i eat the steak
well done and say thank you because the
little doesn't matter anymore
if you if you want another level of life
get bigger problems and solve bigger
problems literally solve bigger problems
and watch your life go to another level
watch the little fall away the stuff
that used to bug you be like why did i
let that bug me get a deeper set of
problems and solve that
and when you're done with that solve the
next one and when you're done with that
solve the next one instead of solving
hundred dollar problems you know my wish
for you is solve million dollar problems
they're the same amount of stress if you
need a hundred bucks to pay the bill or
you need a million i assure you it's the
same stress so why not add more zeros if
you
know the product you have the service
you have the love that you have the
person you are if you know it's
authentic it's real it's the best on the
planet then you have to do everything in
your power to get people to take action
i say this all the time but the movie
field of dreams with kevin costner years
ago they said if you build it they will
come they won't come they just won't
there's outliers that every once in a
while somebody builds something that
goes viral but most of the time when you
see a product that's working you see
someone who's evolving through a company
has a great relationship it's because
they know how to be persuasive they know
how to sell but i want to teach you two
things today there are emotional buyers
and there are logical buyers and if you
are just attracting one or the other
then you're doing everyone a disservice
so think about an emotional purchase
if you ever watched an infomercial if
you ever bought that tiny little hose
that is like this big it's a tight you
know it can fit in your hand and when
you
plug it in and you turn the weave screw
it on you turn the water on it gets 50
feet long right when you see something
like that an emotional you make an
emotional decision you got two minutes
like that hose looks great and you buy
it that's it that's an extreme example
and maybe it sits in your garage you
never use it i guarantee there are
things in your life you bought making an
emotional decision that's okay we need
emotions to move us forward so some
people are not i don't want to say it's
in a bad way but some people are
rational buyers i'm an irrational buyer
from the top looking down when i see
something i like if i go buy a new car
if i walk on the dealership i see the
car but i like i want to leave there in
25 minutes with that car i'm irrational
i'm emotional if i'm if i'm watching a
video online or i'm at a live event and
i see something i like there's zero i'm
not waiting to
research my heart tells me it's good my
gut instinct tells me i'm good i'm
buying it so i am an emotional
irrational buyer but that's only a small
percent of the world then i'm on the
extreme of i'll do it right now i make
quick decisions on the complete other
extreme are buyers who have to be
extremely logical that means
if this sounds good this car looks good
but i'm going to go home i'm going to
research it i'm going to ask anybody i
know if they have a car like that i'm
going to go check the rating i'm going
to see how many miles per gallon it gets
i'm going to see if there's any flaws is
there any recalls and some people will
will just do that logical searching all
the way so that's the extreme so what i
want to share with you today
is when you're selling anything when
you're persuading someone it doesn't
matter again if it's getting a promotion
from your boss it's making more money
it's selling your product or service i
want you to think of
of attracting and fulfilling both of
them you need to get people emotional
people don't make decisions without
being emotional be connected feel moved
have a feeling inside but then if you
cover the logical part for those that
want to overthink then you can really
compound and exponentially grow your
sales so for example this past weekend i
was at an event and i spoke on stage and
i offered a 16 000 mastermind incredible
training worth every dime there were the
irrational emotional buyers like me who
took action immediately i would have
taken action halfway through the
presentation but then there was some
people who waited
until the second day and some people
that are very logical waited until the
third day last minute right before they
walked out the door and the sales were
about equal the emotional and the
logical but here's the thing i want you
to be careful of in your own life
make sure you don't get so logical and
need every eye dotted and every t
crossed that you never make a decision
you never pull the trigger every year
like i'm gonna i should have i would
have it's because you're you probably
have beliefs from parents beliefs from
teachers that you need to research that
you need to look before you leave
i have the i have the thoughts of
jump out of the plane grow wings on the
way down because he who hesitates loses
so two things i want to share if you're
selling if you want to fuel your company
your life you want to persuade people
remember some people make emotional some
people make logical decisions merge the
two together sales will increase in your
own life don't get so logical that you
missed out on amazing opportunities i
remember in my own life when i started
getting success i was working my guts
out i was working on cars during the day
i was working at real estate at night
and then then before when before i did
my first like education course
i was doing cars during the day real
estate at night and setting alarm at
five in the morning from five to like
nine in the morning i'd work on trying
to figure out how to write a course on
how to do what i did in my life and how
to be successful i was so confused
i did all that and guess what i did that
for years for years i'm just being
honest i put in lots and lots of hours i
had fun i enjoyed myself i played hard
too but i put in a lot of time
but then when it finally hit and i got a
little momentum
do you know i heard a lot of my friends
say oh you lucky
in fact i had a joke for a while made me
think i had a joke for a while that when
i try something new that's out of the
norm which most people wouldn't try
people either say oh you dean got lucky
you lucky
or if i tried and failed it's like i
knew that idiot wouldn't make it there's
nothing in between and you know what
awesome
screw it i don't care i don't dislike my
friends who said all that stuff i'm
still friends with them some of them
said fifth grade
but they're gonna look through life
through a lens of
they're satisfied with okay they're
satisfied making okay money they're
satisfied with okay relationship they're
satisfied with being an okay parent
they're satisfied with an okay career
that doesn't light them up screw that
i'm not satisfied with i'd rather fail
miserably if i look back on my deathbed
would you you too let me ask you would
you like to look back on your deathbed
and be like hey you know what played it
safe didn't go after anything but you
know i lived an okay life
[ __ ] that excuse my language i it just i
felt like saying it and i said it and if
you have someone younger listen i'm
sorry i feel bad now but that's the
emotion i feel and if you're listening
to me if you're listening to my podcast
then you feel the same way people will
buy from you
and learn from you when they feel
understood not when they understand you
do you hear that that's one of the
biggest secrets to my success people
will buy from you do business from you
with you learn from you when they feel
understood not when they understand you
most people want to just
vomit up all their experience vomit up
on how good they are vomit up on how
great their product is and you don't
even know what the person on the other
side is thinking think about that with
salesman would you do you like a pushy
salesman when you go to buy a car that
comes out and says i've been doing this
for 30 years i got this i got this
experience this little baby be perfect
for you it's fast it's quick it's it's a
two-seater it's this this this and he
doesn't realize you showed up because
you want an suv because you have four
kids like wouldn't have been better if
you just walked out and said hey man out
looking for a car what's up with your
family what do you got going on and just
listened people buy from you when they
feel understood when there's a
connection i just was having this girl a
conversation with my girlfriend lisa on
the way here and we were talking about
uh the things that drive you and the
things that um that want to be uh you
know it's funny to say like i have so
many different emotions at once
but
she comes from an amazing family just
like you said your wife did yeah like
amazing she has there's five siblings
their parents are together they're on a
text string every day they all talk
every day like her phone's always
blowing up and going off and it's always
inspirational and they're they all
support each other one just lost their
job and their whole family's like well
get together it's finally time you start
your own business anyway and i'll build
the website i'll give you the money like
it's unbelievable what they do and i
love both my parents my mom and dad are
amazing but i didn't have that they
split at three
i was three when they split and i lived
with mom and then dad and graham and
they moved you know i moved 20 times by
time i was 19. right so all this
insecurity so but again that was my
journey it made me the man i am so for
me one of the things
is that i don't have something to refer
to to be a good dad
my father's father was physically abused
all the kids they were some were
sexually abused and his father did that
i think i look at this long lineage of
screwed up graziosis and i knew it was
going to stop with me
like my sister did it she's an amazing
mother
actually my nephew works for me
incredible kids like the greatest kid
you ever met she stopped it and i want
to do the same thing so i'm always like
you and i when we talk later we'll
probably just talk about being a parent
because i love interviewing and talking
to other great parents because i want to
learn because i don't have a blueprint
like i said lisa she's got the blueprint
she grew up from it right so for me i
want to be a better man and always want
to continue to grow so i can set an
example and change
the way my kids see life and experience
life i don't want to raise entitled
brats that's the last thing this world
needs um i want them to have hunger and
drive and be good people and and one
thing i'll share with you um a dear
friend of mine uh he's about 15 years
older than me he said to me and he's
done extremely well just
extremely well and he said
i think at the end of our lives
when you're on your deathbed
i don't think we'll ask any other
question because you're a parent like me
says your dad like me i could see it
because i think the question we're going
to ask ourselves is did we do everything
we could
to give our kids the the tools to live a
fulfilled life i said i mean because i
don't think anything you won't say how
many women did i sleep with how much
money did i make how many buildings that
i buy it'll be like wow did i give the
kids and i said he said you'll be able
to go off to the next place if you could
say yes you did your best because but
what if you can't say that
and for me it's like that's all i think
about it's like that's one of the things
i i can't be the perfect i try i do
everything i can to be a great dad just
like you but fundamentally i want to
give them the tools to be thriving
adults me too and that's just one i mean
yeah that i can talk about that i want
to go conquer something right now
thinking about that listen when i was
working out of that garage
if someone would have come to me and
said hey just want to let you know
someday you're going to be a multiple
new york times best-selling author
someday your brands and your company is
going to break a billion dollars in
sales someday you're going to be a dad
with two amazing kids and you're going
to coach literally coach softball
someday you're going to be able to jump
on private planes and fly and go the
best fishing resort in the world with
your kids for one day to have the time
of your life i'm only referencing that
because we did it about two weeks ago
i'm not saying that to brag but that kid
i'm holding up this picture again where
you could laugh if you're watching this
that kid that scared embarrassed broke
kid
had a vision for moore in his life and
he made it if you would have told me
that at that age i would have said no
wayne
i hope i could make 1500 bucks a week
someday and not have to struggle and
hump it but that was my journey what is
yours
what if every single thing in your life
was designed for you as a test to see if
you really have the grit the courage
the the the the the
the dedication
to be the best version of you and if you
pass the test
you get to live the life that you
deserve not my life not some silly
person you follow on instagram showing
all these pictures and stuff i'm talking
about being the best version of you
there's a next level waiting inside of
you
realize that life is just putting all
these things in your place in your way
to test you pass the test go to the next
level live the life you deserve we've
all been told that money doesn't grow on
trees and what that is is we feel that
money is scarce or in fact
we live in a fear that it's going to run
out or going to vanish and we know that
money doesn't vanish money is not going
away there's the same amount of money if
not more around the world than there's
ever been it's not getting smaller think
about that like really think what i just
said money is not shrinking right in
fact
this year in america alone and i've said
the stats a lot of you have heard this
but because it boggles my mind that
there's 1700
new millionaires being created every day
in america
think about that 1700 new millionaires
every single day
in america
is that 80 doing the math yeah like
every hour every every i mean it's crazy
right so think about that and and
i i took some notes here so instead of
instead of the question
and this is this is one i really want
you to think about
what happens is when we think about
money is scarce and it doesn't go on
trees and we have this feeling that it's
getting shrinking and it's going away
what we ask ourselves is this
how do i protect myself how do i save
this money how do i make sure no one
takes what i have
and that mindset keeps you on the
sidelines
i want you to say what about
asking yourself a different question
because here's the thing if money
doesn't disappear if we know it's the
same amount or more can we agree on that
if it's not disappearing then all it is
is money is moving from one group of
people to another group of people same
amount of money
if there's still let's say there's a
hundred dollars and you're moving it
around amongst a bunch of people it's
just who's getting the chunk of it
there's still a hundred dollars the same
sum total is there it's just moving
differently so the question you should
be asking yourself is now how do i hold
on to what i have how do i make sure i
don't lose any of this how do i make
sure you know i keep the lights off at
night i'm not saying you shouldn't be
conservative what i'm saying is instead
of having that mindset what we should be
saying is how do i become the person and
this is one write this down i hope you i
hope you're paying attention here today
guys i hope you're not playing with
social media looking around trying to
focus on this because the question
should be how do i become
the person where the money is moving to
rather than away from
right just the same little same thought
process just a different shift instead
of instead of thinking money is scarce
and it's going away no there's 1700 new
millionaires a day in america alone
being created right now money's not
getting scarce it's just those people
money is flowing to them and somebody
else who's standing there trying to
protect the little protect themselves
and and being thinking a scarce mindset
their money is slowly
going away now i am surely not going to
be an advocate
or say that you shouldn't be
conservative that you shouldn't save
money that you shouldn't be smart with
your money of course you should but
here's what i know
in the evolution of my life of going for
that kid living in a bathroom with my
dad and not having money and all those
things and i'm not saying that to give
you my my my my pitch or my story but
when i look back at when i tried to save
and be conservative because i listened
to you know maybe grandparents that went
through the depression or listened to
people that you know is like you're
crazy
what i realize is
when you change your mindset on money
when you gain the capabilities
and when you take action
it is
in my opinion you can disagree with me
in my opinion
money is easier to flow to you and make
it than it is to save it i even look at
that in my business i'm like hey let's
tighten up on expenses and i'll look
through all these things like okay if we
tighten up all those because we're such
a big company now we could save this
much but if we if i write a new book if
i start a new campaign if i do some more
real estate deals i can bring in this
much with a little with the same amount
of effort like save this much or just
make this much how to hold it keep
everybody there keep the lights on i'm
going to go make it over here now i
might be an extreme but i'd like to give
you a little bit of that
that if we stand on the sidelines
envying those making more being not
jealous but like desiring what other
people have but we're afraid because we
want to hold on to what we have and be
afraid to take action do you want to
know one of the biggest secrets to sales
in our world today right now where i i
believe where we're at
is authenticity
people just want to know what's real
what's raw and they want it from your
heart
if you think about the people that
you've connected with in your life
remember this phrase
people will buy from you say yes to you
when they feel understood not just when
they understand you
i want you to listen to that again
people will buy from you say yes to you
when they feel understood not just when
they understand you
let's take let's take an example then
i'm going to circle back around with
authenticity so i'm going to park
authenticity put a pin in it and come
back to it but think about this
think about let's just say the
quintessential sales area is used cars
or new cars and i know that world is
changing but let's just talk about uh
the way it was for the last 100 years 50
years
saturday afternoon your car shopping you
pull into the dealership there's 10
dealers waiting in the window waiting
for you to come in
you pull up
one of them gets a high five your turn
go go chat with the guy in the tesla or
whatever right
now think about this scenario same
scenario
person comes up
and says
hey glad for glad you're here today nice
saturday right hey listen i just wanted
to let you know
i've been selling these cars for 27
years i know i'm inside and out i've
been voted the top sales guy 14 months
out of the last five years
and it's because i care about the client
this is what i do and i can see
you're here today and
you'd love us a sporty car but
let me guess
you want something that's a little good
on the gas maybe eco-friendly so you can
do your part i got this amazing
two-seater it's fast it's eco-friendly
it's this it's that let's go take a look
at
now that's a sales guy that could make a
job for 27 years and he wants you to
understand him
but what if
you went there that day
because you want you just had your third
child
and you want your wife to have something
that's not a minivan but the big suvs
are too clunky you're just looking for
something in the middle nothing even
close
now that same sales person wants you to
understand him what if there's a sales
person that comes out
and you see him walking over to you and
you're like oh [ __ ] here comes this
sales guy you roll down your window or
you get out
and he says hey listen first off i know
it's a saturday we all work on
commissions
authenticity transparency we all work on
commissions it's my turn up i gotta i
get you but i just want to tell you
let me just back up i just want to ask
why are you here today what's your
family like
what uh how can i serve you tell me a
little bit about you
and all of a sudden the person says wow
immediately who do you have rapport with
immediately
sales guy number two because he wanted
he wants the you to feel understood and
probably not on purpose that's just who
he is all of a sudden you go well we had
our third kid you go oh my god i'm on my
fourth i get it my wife hated the
minivan when i thought about bringing it
to her house she was like are you crazy
but then i looked at the monster
escalating she's that's a bus
but we figured out something in between
would you be open to something kind of
in the middle it's kind of like the
sporty uh
smaller suv all of a sudden you're
laughing high-fiving talking about the
names of your kids what's going on in
school that playing softball or baseball
and what they do and all of a sudden
you're sitting in a car going it's a
good guy
and what did he do most of the time
he listened
he was authentic he was transparent i do
things the way i want to do i want to
make my own rules i don't want anybody
to tell me how what kind of husband i
can be if i want to take off the mill a
day and romance my wife because we have
the most amazing relationship in the
world it might sound boring to you or
that sounds ugh but that's me
i will fight for that i will die for
that that is my why being a leader to my
incredible team that's like my family
learning and growing and help impact the
world help unite us unlock arms so we
can help shift the world how do we
change the global economy by changing
the economy in our homes how do we
change the global conversation by
changing the conversation in our homes
we are the change we affect the change
no one's coming to fix it to me that's
my why i hope you can hear it i hope you
can feel it it comes from my heart
so when i'm standing on one side of the
ravine and i see where i want to go on
the other before i even know how i'm
going to get in there i know my why and
i'm getting over there no matter what if
i got to get bloody bruised up fail
whatever it takes i'm getting to the
other side
are you do you know the true reason why
you're listening to this why you want
another level if you don't go find it
i promise you when you find it nothing
will stop you not a brick wall not a
steel girder not dirt a mount nothing a
mountain won't stop you when you know
your true why you cannot
create your compelling future until you
decide what your painful future is
because this will get you this is once
you get around here now all of a sudden
you're going up the loop like you
projected if i don't do crap i'll be
stuck right here
but now that i felt that way what would
be ideal
what would be ideal
what's a compelling future for you
for me
in my relationship
tony i'm going to give my credit to my
boy tony
i've done all these things before but he
made me do it in front of him let me go
in the other room and do it i took a
piece of paper when it comes to
relationships i made a line down the
middle and i put on the left side
what was an absolute must in the next
relationship i have and on the right
side i put absolute
unacceptable
and i literally wrote down things that
i'm just being honest i i wrote down
everything i wrote down someone who
loves my children i know this would be
hard someone who will love my children
as if their own
someone who works on their personal
growth someone who's a go-getter someone
who knows that we're flawed and we're
all trying to get better i just wrote
down all these things that i was looking
for seemed like it was too good to be
true and i put what was not acceptable
someone doesn't have a big heart someone
won't accept my children someone wants
to fight with my ex or fight with other
people someone who likes confrontation i
won't accept anyone who doesn't you know
want to work on their health and their
growth i wrote all this stuff down
seemed crazy it was my compelling future
i stared at it and i looked at it and i
felt so good and it gave me my true
north i projected being alone and
staying the way i was and i also wrote
down a compelling future i write down a
compelling future in my business all the
time remember what i said about that
indian proverb a man with his health
has a million wishes and
a man would without his health has put
one
i don't care how successful you get how
much money you make how much love you
have in your life without health we have
anything we have nothing
and i see it just this little
inconvenience imagine when you're if
your health is stripped away if you're
if you're going through something in in
the health world i'm sorry i send you my
love my prayers my empathy and if you're
not don't take it for granted without
our health
life nothing else matters so get up make
better decisions this week to eat make
better decisions on sleep make better
decisions on exercise
we only have one body whether you
believe in god the universe whatever you
believe in we were given this one body
this one unique dna this one chance to
thrive make all the money in the world
find all the abundance happiness and joy
but take care of you along the way
here's the thing when you're going if
you're going through a really tough time
right now
it's like it's hard to go oh this is for
me i'm going to be so much better in 20
years yeah it's like no you don't but
that process i told you if you have to
watch this video or listen to this audio
again
that process is what i use today because
my businesses and companies are thriving
right now my book just passed six
hundred thousand copies
like where every part is going tony
robbins and i are launching a company my
buddy brendan bashard and i own
growth.com that company is crushing we
have all these different things going on
but
i'm not naive enough to think omar i
promise you i'll be going through some
kind of
fest
in the next three to five years it just
happens they change a regulation
something goes wrong
a publisher that owes your money goes
bankrupt like these things happen it's
part of the business yeah and the more
you go through it
the more you're like i got this what's
coming next and the more you create a
framework i didn't have a framework i
looked back in retrospect how did i get
through all those things and i did have
a framework now i know it it's like okay
something goes wrong there was a
situation in my life i didn't plan it
okay i got to deal with it i could stack
the negative or i could stack the
positive i could focus on what goes
wrong focus on what go right i can focus
on who i want to be or i don't want to
be i can create my compelling future i
can go out and obsess and gain
capabilities and then after i gain the
capabilities you gotta do the most
important thing you have to have courage
you have to jump out of the plane and
grow wings on the way down and that's
the hardest thing if you are listening
to this podcast you're listening to
other podcasts that motivate you give
you capabilities to go faster quicker
make more money have more freedom
control in your life all those types of
things but none of it listen to me
listen to this clearly maybe for the
first time in your life really hear me
none of it is possible
if your confidence is down
so i want you to think about the things
in your life
that steal your confidence and remember
when i say steal your confidence i don't
mean that you have a hundred percent of
confidence and you do something and you
go to twenty percent or ten percent i'm
talking about when your confidence is
off just five percent do you make smart
decisions when your confidence is down
do you go after the business do you ask
for the money do you start the the
website do you do you uh get the girl do
you get the promotion do you ask your
boss for a raise no your confidence is
down you that's when you start saying
well maybe this is good enough maybe my
relationship is good enough i should
just be happy with what i got i should
just be happy with the money i make
screw that
if you were happy you wouldn't be here
you'd be doing something else right now
besides listening or watching me so
let's just face the facts where you are
right now is not sufficient for you
doesn't mean it's horrible but it's not
enough
and if you want to get to that next
level you need to protect your
confidence
by any shape measure or form protect it
so what are the things that dig your
confidence i realized
at an early early time it's probably
been 10 years
that watching the news for me when i
watch the news and i see that it looks
like the world is going to hell in a
hand basket or what the president is
saying today or what congress is saying
or you listen to the left or the right
or or people in the middle if you listen
to all the gun violence and all like all
the news does for me is make me question
where the world is going in my next
level so for 10 years now i've been on a
news diet i don't watch the news i have
no clue what's going on nor do i care it
was the biggest transformation in my
life
i where i want to spend my time i want
to spend time with my family the people
i love my kids my team members they
deserve the best of me they don't
deserve dean at 95 confidence they
deserve a hundred percent and if i watch
the news it it brings it down so i won't
be the best team leader i won't be the
best father i won't be the best man i
can be i won't be the best uh
inspiration for you so screw the news it
dings my confidence it's out i've been
on a news diet i challenge you to do the
same thing for me i don't know about you
but if if you have your phone i'm
recording on my phone here i'm stopped
now i can talk to you um but i don't
know this is my wallet but if you ever
look at your phone if it dings someone
texts you or calls you and you look at
you go oh should i answer this now
should i answer it later to me that robs
my confidence i don't want those people
in my life i either have to set
boundaries
or have to push them out of my life
listen let's just be honest stop feeling
bad for other people stop dimming your
glow stop talking about your
aspirational next level stop fantasizing
about your dreams in front of people
because it may insult them or make them
feel inferior or they may tell you
you're a dreamer if that's the case push
them out of your life or become teflon
and don't listen to their
i'm realizing
year after year after year that i judged
myself by an outdated scorecard i judged
myself that if i wasn't good at reading
i wasn't good in school i didn't get
good grades and i didn't go to college
that i guess i was going to be a loser
no
no
that young man has so much empathy has
so much drive screw math don't ever get
good at math in fact never look at math
again for the rest of your life that's
what we have calculators for that's what
we have accountants for screw that if
you're good at math be an accountant run
the books but if you're not find your
passion get so good at something that
you pay people to do the rest i listen
when i think about my my fight my
mission my drive i want every single
insecure person i want every person who
thinks they're bad at something every
person who's been told they're a loser
been told they're a dreamer been told
they're stupid to show the world that
they were wrong
they are wrong
my math tea my mrs thompson she treated
me like in seventh grade
i remember passing her years later later
in a little ford beat up escort
like like i'm not saying money has to do
with everything but who was she to judge
me i'm not mad at her in fact i'm happy
for her she was part of the ingredient
for the growth in my life but miss
thompson later on in life i found
struggled all the time financially
because she couldn't even get the
regular teaching job she had the the she
was in the you know helping me that the
people with that struggled and she was
frustrated because she couldn't even get
raised up to the job she wanted so she
was pissed she took it out on me she had
an outdated scorecard
and she projected that on me but what if
i didn't change what if i didn't find
out that she was wrong and i was right
i've impacted more lives in a day than
she has in her entire life and i don't
i'm not being rude but i'm just being
honest she was a frustrated teacher i
found out also she was left-handed where
she went to school when she was a little
girl because she was older they thought
left-handed was evil they tied her left
hand behind her back and made her right
right handed she was a frustrated
teacher
and she almost ruined my dreams
who are you letting ruin in your dreams
what score card are you judging yourself
by screw that this is your time
this is your opportunity this new world
that we live in with access like you
listening to me right now i'm shooting
this while i'm in my car i'm going to a
dentist appointment but i have this on
my heart we have access to so much
knowledge we have access to information
there's more millionaires being made
every day right now than ever before in
history this is your time there's no
better time there's no different time
this is your time
but you're gonna
but the only way it'll happen is if you
change the story in your head if you say
i suck at math i can never do this i'm a
loser no screw that never focus on math
ever again maybe some people would tell
you that my advice is bad i'm sorry it
worked for me it worked for every
billionaire i've ever met every
multi-millionaire i've ever met i met
presidents i met i spent time with joel
osteen i've spent time with michael
jordan all of them have the same stuff
so
could they be wrong
and my grumpy miserable frustrated
seventh grade teacher was right i don't
think so
change the score card change your
desires find your passion don't when
people tell you stop dreaming tell them
i'm sorry you gave up on yours i'm not
quite there yet
that's the response you need to share
i've failed miserably in my life but
i've had massive success
i'm sharing this with you today so you
can avoid the potholes so you can avoid
avoid the pitfalls so you could go
faster to your next level why go through
your own trial and error when i've been
here so do this exercise don't just
think about it don't just be inspired do
it this week start writing down
everything in your life that makes you
feel a little bit less than confident
someone in your life a relationship
watching the news working on your
weaknesses
redundant work negative people whatever
it is start recognizing it and start
eliminating those things in your life
start figuring out how you could push
them out or become teflon or switch it
or adjust it or go on a one week news
night just go this week without watching
one bit of news and use that time that
you'd watch the news or surf online
looking at stupid crap that doesn't do
anything for your life use that time
working on you
read a book
read powerful by peggy mccall read shoe
dog by phil knight read
principles by ray daly read something
that takes you forward and eliminate the
crap that holds you back how important
is it for you to surround yourself with
a growth mindset okay when i say a
growth mindset it's
being around books people environment
videos that drive you that push you
don't keep you back you see
i'll give you an example this morning i
got up at 4 45 and i went to the gym and
i met my buddy trent shelton if you
don't know trent you should follow him
he's an amazing guy ex-nfl player killed
it for the colts and now he's killing it
online inspiring millions of people his
last video just went uh he put it up
maybe two weeks ago i saw it had 24
million views already this guy's a
player one of the top influencers in the
world so this morning he's in town we
both spoke at my buddy brendan
bouchard's event uh yesterday and the
day before and he's in town i said hey
you want to work out at 5 30 at this new
gym i go to so he's like yeah so he
meets me there at 5 30. now trent's in
his 30s um i'm two months away from 50
and the reason i share that is not to
brag but the truth is i stayed up kind
of late last night and i was tired this
morning i've had this on and off cold i
think it's allergies whatever so i'm not
feeling the best so i got out of bed and
i'm like wow i'm meeting trent
i'll just you know i'll do my best i can
to to uh get a decent workout and well
the trainer i have now i haven't had a
trainer like three years this guy's a
monster i mean a monster as far as
killing you right so i show up and trent
is so positive that we subliminally
inspired
each other to go to another level we
freaking killed it i mean he's an ex-nfl
player in amazing shape he's running a
marathon in a couple months and i just
didn't want to be the older guy falling
behind in fact we were dead even on
weight on reps on everything through
this workout and it was his growth
mindset it was his
desire to always grow is the same as
mine it kept pushing me and motivating
me now simultaneously
how does that work in your business life
with you making more money
are you surrounding yourself with the
right books and the right people that
say yes you can there is a next level
yes is the perfect time yes you may fail
yes it may be hard but it's worth it and
you can do it or do you have people in
your life that are saying well i don't
know if it's the right time i know it
can work but i don't know if it can work
for you or maybe the market's too
saturated or it doesn't it's just not
your time or you don't have the
education or the right partners the same
when you go to the gym if i would have
showed up this morning and trent would
have said man i'm a little tired i was
up late yeah me too we would have
screwed that workout up we it just it
literally is that simple so let me ask
you again are you surrounding yourself
with a growth mindset tell someone in
your life the truth tell them if they're
if they're failing tell yourself the
truth tell the people around you tell
co-workers but find a way to do it with
class try find a way to do it with
empathy but find a way to realize that
telling the truth solves problems brutal
honesty transparency authenticity sets
your soul free in a way that again i
can't quantify i can just say to you you
need to try it what if it's just one
week your life where you don't again you
don't talk about people one week your
life where you tell the people in life
in your life what you really feel just
in a great you know in the best way
possible what if you are open to hearing
the truth from other people about you
and instead of getting defensive and
studying like letting your ego take
control you go wow could some of this be
true
i've done so much of this going through
a divorce and wanting to be friends with
my ex and want my kids to thrive that i
learned so much about me
and i feel i'm on a completely different
level and i want that experience for you
so
brutally honest and transparent this
week try it see how it sticks your next
level of life lives on the other side of
your biggest worry your biggest fear
your biggest obstacle and i can only say
it by going through it as i'm repeating
myself because i want to hammer this
home
face it deal with it fix it and watch
how much you grow i can honestly say i'm
in a place right now that i'm blessed
that i went through it i'm a better
version of me the mistakes i made i'll
never make again and the next level of
life is just an inch away from me
remember when something goes wrong and
you can think about this too like from a
girlfriend leaving you to losing your
money to the business didn't work
and then you don't just go wow she left
me you're like wow she left me i'll
never be in love i'm gonna be miserable
i'm gonna maybe i'll be bad to the next
girl i'll be alone forever i'm never
gonna have kids like you stack all this
negativity when it rains it pours yeah
you paint this negative
future and i think we're designed that
way because i can remember staying up
all night just stacking stuff like
so when that happened i was already uh
supporting my mom and dad i had never
work i've never worked for anybody in my
entire life and when that happened i
started thinking i started stacking all
the negativity i was like oh my god i'm
going to go broke oh my god it's going
to be in the paper oh my god all my
friends are like i told you you couldn't
make it dreamer oh yeah and then i said
oh my god i'm probably gonna have to go
to work so i can keep supporting my
parents like i stacked so much like one
thing happened and i'm stacking like a
mile
right so
what's true most of us deal with some
variation of this so so what i've
learned through the years and i didn't
know i did it then but i kind of i call
it this like success loop now i'll just
go through it quick because you said how
put it in real process like this was a
pivotal moment in my life like
i didn't have a million and a half
dollars and i invested all the money i
had into my next business and that
business was eating money and now this
money was going away and i owed money
and my attorney said i had to file
bankruptcy stacked all the negativity
didn't sleep sick to my stomach but then
what shifted it is somehow now it's a
process now this is a process i go
through and take this process don't do
this to yourself
i started stacking what could go right
and it was kind of off balancing what
could go wrong it was like my brain want
to go wrong like no what about right
right wrong wrong so i was balancing and
it started to i calmed down a little bit
as soon as i calmed down i start
focusing on solutions like how can i fix
this how can i get through it no i'm not
filing bankruptcy i worked on solutions
but then what really got me is
i started thinking of who i didn't want
to be
i didn't want to be somebody who used to
be successful i didn't want my friends
to say ah dreamer knew it yeah i didn't
want to be the guy that almost made it
and had that story for 20 years like
back in the night back in the early
2000s i was almost there but then this
guy ripped me off and screwed me up like
how many people do you know that have
that bitter moment exactly oh big
business it's all crooks right right the
real estate market turned and robbed my
life that was 20 years ago time to jump
back on the horse right right my boss
fired me my partner stole my money my
wife cheated on me and left me okay
that's your like you can either loathe
on that and focus on that or you can
learn from it call it research and
development and go forward so i started
i started saying to myself do who do you
want to be the guy that used to be or
made almost was successful and then i
started writing down who i wanted to be
i wanted to be the guy that got through
an almost impossible situation no money
a million and a half in debt
partner i had to go to court to take
back a broken company i want to be the
guy that gets through this i want this
story figure out what success means to
you
and go after that and don't worry about
the other stuff experiences remember the
moments in between they're priceless yes
money can make all those things easier
so go after it but spend the money you
have on things that are smart make sure
taken take an audit what are you
spending money on can you gain more
education can you gain more wisdom can
you get in a mastermind group can you
can you learn can you hire a mentor can
you start that business can you can you
sacrifice here that doesn't really move
the needle of your happiness to to plant
apple trees i always say planting apple
trees sucks you plant them they don't
produce fruit for six to ten years but
once they do they produce forever are
you planting any apple trees in your
life are you looking for the instant
gratification right so think about all
those things i was all over the board
and decide this week are you spending
money on the right things do you really
know what success is do you realize that
some of the things that you might be
striving for will give you a bump of
happiness for a week a month six months
but they're not sustainable you being
the best version of you you
understanding what success means and you
gaining the knowledge and the wisdom to
get there will fulfill you in ways that
i could only i could only emphasize with
all of me with all my enthusiasm are the
way to pure happiness to pure abundance
at the end of your life you could say
i've made millions and i lost my family
i made millions i don't have any friends
or you could say i made millions and i
lived life with fruitful relationships
with fruitful experiences and i put my
money in the most important places to
get me there don't be satisfied don't
ever be satisfied with okay don't be
satisfied with good
go for excellent go for outstanding you
know what your potential is that's when
that that icky creepy eerie feeling you
have inside what why i just want more
well it's because you deserve more
you're talented enough you have the
capabilities if you suck at some stuff
great join the crowd so do i i suck at
more stuff than i'm good at but i got
really great at the stuff i'm good at
and so can you you don't want to look
back at the end of your life go why
didn't i make that decision why didn't i
get healthier sooner why didn't i fix
that bad relationship why didn't i say
no or end a bad relationship or why
didn't i start that business do you
think you'd be better starting and
failing something with your passion or
sticking and being safe and something
that's slowly robbing your life your
juice for life again i know it's easier
said than done you have life you have
bills you have mortgages you have
relationship you have kids we have all
this stuff but man in the end of the day
are we going to look back and say i'm so
glad i played safe i'm so glad i didn't
to try to do something older i'm so glad
i just i just played small and didn't
reach my full potential hell no not one
of you watching me you were not the type
to watch me if that's the life you want
so today i'm not encouraging you to do
something drastic i'm just encouraging
you to investigate
do the exercise look into your future on
two different paths look down the road a
year five ten even twenty and see what
path
you think you should take reverse
engineer it and decide today listen when
you put yourself out there like i have
with infomercials and writing books and
on social media and and you know
facebook and instagram when you're out
there putting your message you have to
be willing to
take on the haters take on the naysayers
take on the people that want to
criticize you but let me start first off
by saying
that they've never made a statue of a
critic
they've only made the statue of the
people that were once considered crazy
nuts taking a chance a dreamer
insane i mean think about that the the
revolutionaries the ones that made an
impact the ones that changed the laws
the one the ones that ended the wars
the ones that created freedom for a
group of people or a country or or or or
their race
were always the crazy ones they were the
ones on the edge that had to absorb the
criticism how to listen to all the
naysayers and i would say that feedback
can either be the anchor that you drag
across the desert
or it can be the wind behind your sail
in life
however we frame an action however we
interpret an action is the result we get
it's the feeling we get if you're an
underdog if you're someone who says you
can't you could take the power of it
won't work for you or you can't do that
or you're not smart enough or why are
you trying to pretend to be something
you're not you could take that and say
uh yeah that's what they think i should
play small or you can reverse that and
say wow is that what they think of me
wait till i show them remember how it
goes in has nothing to do with how we
interpret it it could be our fuel or it
could be our kryptonite how long do you
hold a grudge
when something goes wrong in your life
when someone isn't fair to you someone's
unfaithful to you someone lies to you
things didn't go right they didn't ask
you to the movie they didn't ask you to
be a partner
they were just something that rubbed you
wrong it was your perception of
something that offended you and you were
upset or you held a grudge or had a
grudge so let me just ask you something
how long does it take you to get over
that
it's a really important question because
here's what i know and all my obsessive
study of successful people happier
people yes i say success i mean money in
a lot of cases but i also mean abundance
and joy would you take a million dollars
would you take 10 million right now to
be miserable for the rest of your life i
doubt it so that's why we talk about the
millionaire success habits as the
foundation for all success right um so
let me just ask you how long do you hold
on to a grudge
and let me just ask you if you're
someone who holds on for a long time how
does that serve you how does that feel
when you obsess about why could this
happen to me that is the
crappiest question in the world or or
why would they do that to me or here's
even a better one i didn't deserve that
in most cases probably all of those are
true but even though it's true
it doesn't serve you in any way possible
in fact it does the opposite of serve
you because it's not like god or whoever
you believe in the universe or or or or
your creator whatever you believe in
comes down and says
you didn't deserve that i'm sorry it
happened
who are we looking for that life we get
our ass kicked in life that that's okay
the people who can handle that the ones
that can handle the problems the ones
that can learn from it are the ones that
go to the next level so let me just ask
you again
are you someone that gets over something
right away or are you someone that holds
on to it because if you hold on to it
the only thing that can do is delay the
progress of your life i screwed up in my
marriage my ex screwed up we both
screwed up we we admit our faults we
admit where we ignored the wrong things
we pushed things off so far it was too
late by the time we wanted to fix it
with all the good i've done with all the
positivity i messed up and and i can
admit that and i hope that you can admit
where we mess up we do but how do i
honor those mistakes by never making
them again i will never make the same
mistakes i give my ex the most respect
love i'm still her family she's still
got my back i still got hers we still
are going to make sure the kids are
first
and i see another level of life for me
and my kids beyond anything i could ever
imagine i listen to people all the time
and they're always telling me their old
story yeah you know they're just saying
living they don't know a story and they
don't know we don't know it but the just
the concept of a story overall that we
tell ourselves you talk you speak about
that probably more eloquently than
anybody that i've heard so just touch on
the whole concept of the cognizance of
the story we tell ourselves yeah so i
think i mean even with me like i said i
had to catch myself i was telling myself
a story that maybe i should have stayed
with the real estate brand maybe success
there's so many people deluding it that
haven't had the success they don't
recognize the real thing like i i had
all kinds of stories i'd look at people
like god that guy seems like a scammer
why is he got three million followers
like i started telling myself stuff yeah
and i felt bad yeah and i wasn't having
the momentum that i know how to create
and then all of a sudden i changed that
story and i said no i know what i want
to do for people i'm the freaking best
at it there's nobody better than me give
me a year i'll be far surpassed and then
they'll realize they're actually
learning from someone who's done it and
nothing changed god didn't come down the
weather didn't change my bank account
didn't change there's nothing changed
except my story so so the part that i
want to share is
i did a uh i did an interview with a
young kid casey adams yeah
so he asked me a great kid and he said
hey man at the end maybe he asked you he
said you were as a young kid there's a
lot of young kids listen what would be
the one thing that you would tell people
and i'd never been asked that i and
literally what just came out is
that
your thoughts lie to you
and to question those thoughts because
when i look back at what stalled me or
almost had me fail or the people around
me it had nothing to do with who's
president whether you like the president
or not if he's crazy or not the economy
or your family your friends holding you
down a job that takes too much time it's
never any of that the only thing
standing between you and your next level
a better version of you not not being me
not being not just a better version of
the only thing and you might not believe
me right now but i promise you someday
what you will the only thing standing
between you and your next level better
version of you is the story you tell
yourself and why you can't get it
that's it so good
i mean i think about it i remember
having a real estate deal when i was
broke and it's a million dollar deal and
i got four bucks in the bank never
saying i'll never get this money i'll
never and i never could and all of a
sudden i'm like no screw that i'm
getting this money and i would find it
it didn't matter if i had to beg borrow
steal
you know some with the banks some on
credit cards borrowing from this guy i'd
make the deal happen when nothing else
changed i didn't inherit money i didn't
get smarter my iq didn't go up i didn't
have a harvard education
i just willed it by changing the story
so i guess an easy way for you guys to
think about right now if you talk about
what you would where you would love to
be it's a year from now it's the
greatest year of your life and you'd
love to be there i'd love to be
you know working on my own on my own uh
company i'd love to launch my own
company i'd like to have more time with
my wife or my husband and my kids just
say butt
and then fill in whatever that butt is
that's usually your story but my boss
keeps me my boss keeps me too busy but
my wife doesn't support me but my family
thinks i'm crazy but i'm not that smart
but it takes money to make money that's
your story that's the thing that's your
anchor you're dragging across the desert
flip that story and immediately that
becomes the wind behind your sail i mean
i don't want to oversimplify it but at
this phase of my life it is
oversimplified
and i still run into it i will catch
myself being in a space worried about
something worried about some of my kids
worrying about anything and i'm like why
is this bugging me why is this oh cause
i'm telling myself lies i'm telling
myself some stuff i change it and then i
change in a second it's not the objects
it's the things that we get to
experience
so you can't buy your way i i had a lot
of pain as a kid which we all didn't i
know i thought for a time in my life
that money would fix that
and
there's nothing more than the experience
my daughter's on her first trip with me
as a business trip this will last this
is worth millions to me i'd give up all
my books to have that so it's the it's
the moments and the experience not the
things i'm more motivated today than
i've ever been because now i realize
i was put on this earth to share a story
to give capabilities to make impact so
the deans that are in their 20s right
now thinking i don't think i could do
this it's the wrong time wrong president
i missed my window all that all that
same fear was the same fear as i had i
wasn't smart enough i didn't have the
money to start no one gives me a chance
no one believes me people think i'm
insane people call me dreamer like i'm
the oddball i'm the black sheep of the
family i'm the underdog all those
feelings so many people have and they're
one shift one little shift not a million
away from getting course corrected
they're one shift away from being 30 or
20 years later like i am now and looking
back my brands have broken a billion
dollars in sales from that guy living in
a bathroom working out of an old beat up
barn
right so
i just hope and i know you universe
great people and i love the inspiration
but i hope today you see like i would
love for you to say holy dean's not that
smart
yeah like i would love to say oh my god
if dean could do it i could i have a
seventh grade vocabulary if you read my
books i write the way i talk i mean if
you read my book you know i write it's a
dialogue it's a conversation right so if
nothing else of that story just knowing
that you can because
a lot of times
all someone needs to hear and that's why
i commended you for what you do
sometimes all someone needs to hear is a
story yeah like because the capabilities
are out there the personal growth is out
there the tools are out there but if you
don't have the foundation if someone
doesn't give you a chance if someone
doesn't show you can
then
you start believing you can't and then
there's this certain age where you find
like oh maybe later and and i'm gonna do
another thing to hopefully disturb you
screw later because the last five years
went by too fast for all of you wait
till you get older five years goes by in
a minute and you start saying well let
me take this
job for five years and then i'll work on
me oh let me i'm gonna get married let
me keep the job talking about oh oh we
got pregnant let me wait to the first
kids oh no oh let me wait till they're
in high school oh let me wait till
they're out of college and all of a
sudden you're 60 years old you're like
where the hell did my life go i want it
back you know many people i talked to
like i didn't take chances i didn't take
risks you want to get disturbed picture
being 90 years old and you lived someone
else's life like you always had this
desire to do it you're going to be 90
going can i get another shot like i
don't want that i would much rather do
do you ever hear the theodore roosevelt
quote man in the arena no oh you got to
google it i don't have it but basically
i don't remember it off top my head but
it's really it was this amazing speech
he did in france
and it was like
at a paraphrase you got to find it but
basically it said if you're not in the
arena with me if you're not playing ball
if you're not bloodied if you're not
marred if you don't have failure then
don't dare judge me don't care give me a
word i refuse to listen to anybody who
sits in the sidelines and points fingers
at me it said i would much rather end my
life knowing i tried valiantly and
failed than to sit on the sidelines and
poke fingers but the the ultimate end
would be that i went after it when
everyone told me i got goosebumps
everybody told me i couldn't and i and i
figured it out along the way like it's
such a great quote and basically what
that means to me is
i don't want to sit in the side stands
and wear someone else's jersey on my
back
i want to be on the field even if i'm
losing at least i'm fighting for what i
want so don't wear someone else's jersey
get in the arena and fail like you can't
win unless you're in it i love that how
do we take the goals that you desire how
do we pretend it's six months from now
we're looking backwards and they have
them and attach an emotion to it so it
becomes a feeling so it gets stuck to
your subconscious so it becomes your
reality that's like manifesting on
steroids right but here's something on
the other side that most people don't do
what i'd like you to also do
is i'd like you to pick the goals that
are left that you're going to get done
by the end of the year because you're if
you're listening to me live as i'm doing
these this is half more than halfway
through the year if you if you're
pushing some off until next year that's
fine but the ones you're going to get
done now i want you to think about it
six months from now and you didn't
achieve those goals and you need to feel
that too sit in it it's six months from
now and you're looking back and go wow
another year went by i'm still stuck in
this job another year went by i still
didn't fix this relationship another
year went by i'm staying in abusive
relationship another year went by i
didn't spend the time to try to date and
meet someone new another year went by i
didn't register the url i didn't make
the phone call i didn't dig into the
course i didn't go through the coaching
what will that emotion feel like and let
that bathe in that feeling bathe in
feeling like another year's gone bathed
in the fact of wow at this age i thought
i'd be further ahead because here's what
i know
some of you listen make moves based on a
bigger future you're moving towards
something better you're aspirational
you're inspired you see the bigger life
you see the bigger house the bigger
business the bigger success the bigger
significance in the world the bigger
impact in the world you see it it drives
you
some of you listening right now that
scares you if that scares you then fine
you're a move away from person you want
to move away from a job you don't like
you want to move away from a bad
relationship you want to move away from
being broke you want to move away that's
fine some of you are move away people
some of you have moved towards and
sometimes when you get past the move
away fear
then you can be a move towards person
that's the goal is like move out of fear
and move towards pleasure listen what
drives all of us in life fundamentally
we all boil down to
we want to avoid pain and we want to go
towards pleasure so if that's you which
is everybody in the world use whatever
one it takes so again this is your
wake-up call you're if you're listening
to me like i said live kind of the week
i'm doing them it's more than halfway
through the year what have you
accomplished what have you let slip what
habits have you fallen back into where
have you let your life just go on
autopilot pick the goals you need to get
done this is your action call put them
on a new list put them on a list that
they're going to get done and push like
i said push some of them off but the
ones you push off have an action plan
for them starting next year get the ones
done now remember for future pace six
months from now they are accomplished
attach a feeling attach an emotion cry
if you have to get emotional laugh smile
pretend you're in a situation that that
lights you up but then also do the
opposite side pretend it's six months
from now and none of them got done
they're still in the same place how does
that feel all i know is this
is the last five years went by in a
flash how do you think the next five
years are going to feel and if you don't
make a change now if you don't take
action now what's going to be different
in your life this is the halfway through
the year wake-up call how long does it
take for you to get over a failure i
believe
that the two correlate i believe how
long it takes you to get over someone
taking advantage of you how long you
hold a grudge is probably about the same
amount of time it takes you when you try
a business and it doesn't work out when
you try a partnership and the partner
lets you down
when you go after a course and the
course didn't work
and then
when it doesn't work out
you find reasons why it didn't it
frustrates you it annoys you
and then you go back to the life where
you're at now
i wasn't trying to pigeonhole everybody
who's listening
what i'm trying to do is make a point if
this is just even a fraction of you
these are the types of things doesn't
matter how good you are there's a whole
other level you see i've been
obsessively working on
letting go of grudges and letting go of
failures faster and faster every year of
my entire life
yes i want to fail faster than anyone if
i look back in my 20s being broke not
having money wanting another level of
life didn't go to college
i realized one of the things that i had
that most people didn't is that i could
let go of a failure really fast in fact
even beyond that i could get so pumped
up so motivated so inspired about a
project you ever been there been so
excited about something wanting to do it
like i'm going for this i don't care
what anybody says and you go and you put
all your enthusiasm and you stay up
nights and and you go after it and then
you try it and then it fails they're the
hardest ones to let down it's like a
relationship that you work so hard and
you think the other person's on the same
page as you and they're not all of a
sudden you're let down massively same
kind of feeling when it's a business or
or anything that you're working hard on
or working hard for a swim meet and you
you swim all summer to lose the race
right
i think about that i look back in my 20s
and one thing i had i wasn't smart
enough to read a lot of books or go to
read courses or go to events like i
should have or learn from others as much
as i should have so i'm obsessed with it
now it's why i love training and sharing
and delivering you anything i can to
give you a heads up
is i failed fast i i fail it doesn't
matter how excited i was when i failed
i'd mope and grope and be so pissed off
but by 48 hours later i was over it the
quicker you could focus on how to fix it
the quicker you can learn from your
failure the quicker you can anchor those
emotions those feelings that's when
knowledge becomes wisdom i truly believe
with all of me
that knowledge is something we can all
acquire
information we can all get it there's
more information out now than ever
before in history so knowledge is easy
to find in today's world information
easy to find wisdom ha that's hard to
come by because wisdom is when you take
knowledge take information put it into
play get your ass kicked in some places
learn from your mistakes learn from the
pain and power through
so
again this is what i want you to think
about i don't care where you are if you
hold a grudge shorter than anybody else
go shorter
if you rebound from a failure quicker
than anyone you know rebound quicker
successful people rebound fast and while
they're rebounding they're actually
learning from the horrible experience
they had transform the experience think
of failures
in a way to do an experience transform
experience transformation i just made
that up transform the experience from
something you call a failure something
painful into wow i got that one out of
the way i learned from it i know what to
do next a huge factor standing between
you and the money you deserve are the
beliefs that you have about money so
let's talk about the first belief that
money is scarce
how many times have you heard that money
doesn't grow on trees
it is it's as if we live in constant
fear that somebody's taking money away
you could kill those slides now guys
it's like it'll vanish when the fact is
we know that money doesn't actually
vanish there's the same amount of money
now as there was at all times in fact
there's probably more money money
doesn't go away the fact of the matter
is what happens to money is it transfers
from one person to another it transfers
to the group of people that know how to
make it so the question shouldn't be how
do i protect and save has anybody as is
it really possible to save your way to
being rich or do you have to actually
earn it
you have to earn it but sometimes we
have this ability like save save save
and we're not spending the time that's a
scarcity mindset because it's not going
away the question instead of saying how
do we save it the question needs to be
how do i become part of the group that
not the money is not being transferred
away from how do i become part of the
group that the money is being
transferred to does that make sense can
i get a yup
you can put this up on the screen i've
shared this a lot but i think this
statistic says it all
in 2017
there were
1700 new millionaires not the existing
ones there was 1700 new millionaires
created how often
every day in america more than ever
before in the history of america is this
a good time to make money
and this is a good time for money to be
transferred to you talk to me in your
study about how imperfect you found a
lot of you know successful entrepreneurs
are like how possible is it through
taking just a series of like you said
small pivots small habits that could
totally change the trajectory of your
life can you talk to me about what you
found in your study absolutely so
i love to talk about what's going on
right now so i'm here with you now i
literally was in puerto rico this
morning for breakfast we're in beverly
hills right now yeah i
i was there masterminding with some dear
friends we get together and we find
hidden little spots all over the world
and we meet a couple times a year i i
chartered so i could be here on time i
landed i came here sat down so if i look
a little dish shuffle of a little out on
a plane for seven and a half hours and i
drove in traffic and now i'm here right
but i was there with some people you
might know i was there with lewis howes
russell brunson uh trent shelton um
uh rachel and dave hollis rachel's got
the hottest her books are like number
one and five in the world in amazon
overall she's crushing it um uh i think
i said russell brunson from click
funnels
there was so many i can't even like
people that you like when you watch them
on social media right um
they're just doing amazing things my
buddy brendon burchard right
tony and i are we're doing something
special i want to tell you about that a
little later like if you take tony
robbins and all the people i just
mentioned when you see them
flying on jets doing cool things you're
like god
i could never get there right but we
just mastermind for three days and when
we do we're dear friends and we opened
up
and
i can't tell you who but
there's not one of them that has a story
that's not like severely tragic
i mean two people in the group talked
about this week and how they were
molested when they were young two three
people in the group talking about how
their parents stopped talking to them
because they called them dreamers other
people their parents split and left them
on grandma's doorstep like broke no
school couldn't graduate
like everybody's got the story right and
and i don't say that to make what you're
going through to minimize what you're
going through it doesn't matter if you
came from perfect parents and you still
feel empty on the inside or you came
from unbelievably horrific background
the only thing i know is there is no
ingredient for success that has to do
with your past omar i know a little bit
about your past you struggle with a lot
of things your past was there and was
designed for you to be the man you are
today and those that realize that those
that can say okay today's the shift
today and this is the most important
part what every single one of them had
in common some of the top influencers in
the world that i just mentioned right
influencers might say influencer people
who are really doing it really make an
effect don't just have followers right
um
what they did is found a way and this is
kind of tony robbins 101 is they found a
way to change the story
and
rachel hollis amazing woman like killing
it right now an inspiration to millions
of women
her mom her father her her siblings
didn't believe in what she was doing
they thought she was crazy right she's
gonna her husband i mean there was a
point where her husband where and she
writes about this in her book where he
didn't believe her he's like he thought
personal development was for broken
people yeah and his wife is literally
going to tony robbins and writing books
and doing and he felt that there was a
point in her
and they got the best relationship
you've ever seen like right amazing
companies and it's a classic challenge
that you find in the personal
development world yeah once you've got
into it one's out and one day she either
she literally said to him you're either
on board or you're not like basically
and and the good man that he is he went
to tony robbins with her he started
doing and now they work together
managing this but like
a riff in a relationship like all of
these things but one thing is different
is they found a way to say
i'm not going to fail or be held back
because of these circumstances i'm going
to use them as the fuel to keep me going
the biggest lie we've ever been told
is to work on our weaknesses
all that does is rob your confidence
there's people in this room right now
that are living an okay life because you
feel that you're not good enough you're
not smart enough in a certain area
you're not good at bookkeeping you're
afraid it's sales you're not that
organized screw all that
get amazing at what you're good at and
pay someone to do the stuff you suck at
does that sound right
but we're taught through school we're
taught through life that we have to get
good at everything it's just simply not
true every entrepreneur i know every
successful person i know they just found
what drove them and got them excited and
went for it so i want to encourage you
to to not be fooled by that working on
your weaknesses don't hold that back and
say well i could if i had all those
thoughts what what i mean i wrote a book
someone who was in special reading
barely got out of high school i wrote a
book for gosh sakes i felt so insecure
in my first book and then i give it to
my i give it to my editor and my editor
calls me up and says hey i just want to
tell you this doesn't need a rewrite or
this doesn't need an edit it needs a
whole new rewrite this isn't a book it's
a 300 page conversation don't put this
out there really you don't want to and i
almost threw the book in the garbage
because i started thinking oh who am i
to think i could write i'm not that
smart that's for people who go to
college all those limiting beliefs all
those negative stories and then finally
i i found myself saying no i just want
to give a message to somebody i don't
think people care if it's written
perfect if it sounds like a conversation
great
almost threw that book away and i kid
you not i was an inch away from deleting
the whole book and saying forget about
that i'm great at real estate i
shouldn't have tried to write books
and that book and it hit the new york
times bestseller list in 10 days my
first book
so
i didn't mean to go down that path but
that's i'm really passionate about that
because if i were to listen to my
guidance counselor if i would have
listened to miss thompson in seventh
grade if i would have listened to
everybody else i'd be living their life
instead i'm living mine
i encourage you to live yours when you
work on the things that drive you fuel
you that excites you that you're good at
you find the enthusiasm you break
through i would much rather
give a mediocre listen to this and this
is something that's factual and i've
done it over and over and it always
works i would much rather give a
mediocre opportunity
to someone with passion who knew their
unique ability and were ready to dive in
then give the perfect opportunity
who's to someone that's not in their
unique ability they're just trying to
struggle through it like so many times
we want to we want to get someone to
work with us or for us or next to us
because they're not really doing
anything and we're trying to force them
into doing like god they're not they
don't have anything going on why aren't
they doing this because it maybe it
doesn't align with them you know this
when you feel aligned with something
you're doing do you're unstoppable you
can break through anything nothing's
going to stop you so what i want to do
today before we get done and i'm going
to give you a process to look inside
yourself to find the things that you're
good at that you love to do that also
simultaneously can cut you the biggest
check possible right that's dan sullivan
101. i'm going to give you my version of
it but think if you're aligned with
yourself while the same time you're
doing things that can cut you a bigger
check that's when life exponentially
grows i'd like to talk about what you
have to give up what you have to let go
of
as you take this journey to be more
successful as you gain self-education by
listening to me and others that are
actually playing the game at the highest
level possible as your mind grows as you
shift your thinking
you're gonna have to let go of old
thoughts you're gonna have to let go of
beliefs that may have been your parents
you know sometimes you're republican
because your parents were or you're
democrat because they were you're
christian because your parents were or
you like a certain football team because
your parents like that football team
well it's the same thing here when it
comes to thinking love your parents love
your surroundings for when you grew up
and always cherish that but if there's
another level of life that you desire
and you crave you might have to give up
some of the thinking that they gave you
you might have to give up some friends
along the journey of being an
entrepreneur i can remember being young
and family members telling me how nuts i
was and and that i should stop being a
dreamer family
they kind of get a pass and you go
through and sometimes you're close
sometimes you're not at least in my case
and then it circles back around but
they're your family they're there for
life but i can remember friends
that would always tell me slow down dude
that stuff's for other people you can't
have that and i can remember friends
literally getting mad that i was going
after stuff or investing in real estate
or investing and trying to get on tv
when i did my first infomercial or did
my first course and training on how to
help people go faster and my success
training and i remember along the way
that i would have friends ride with me
to a certain level
and then they couldn't handle any more
because they didn't want to go for it or
they felt inferior because not that i
was successful it felt inferior or maybe
it was ego or maybe it was envy
but they would start
wanting to drag me back to them and the
truth is i had to let them go there was
nothing i can do some some stuck
literally recording this right now in my
house and behind me if you're watching
video over on the other side of the
house is my dearest friend from when i
was literally five six seven years old
we met
he's really one of the few friends that
stuck the whole way i still love the
guys i grew up with but a lot of times
it just changes
because i want to surround myself with
people who have a bigger future mindset
they want tomorrow to be bigger than
yesterday a lot of times in life people
get stuck without even realizing it
doesn't mean they don't have huge hearts
doesn't mean they're amazing doesn't
mean you don't love them and will love
them to a day you die to the day you die
but they have bigger past mindsets so
when you're talking about how tomorrow
could be better they're talking about
back in the good old days when we had
that other president we were back in
college back in high school back when
the economy was different back when the
republicans ran it back when the
democrats or whatever it is they have a
bigger past mindset
and you looking at a bigger future
mindset just conflicts
and you have to let them go what advice
out of all you've learned over a billion
dollars failure mistakes all the success
books he said what have you what could
you tell me it was just one thing which
is a hard thing and i didn't think about
it in advance of course yeah and i said
he said what would it be i said learn to
observe your thoughts
quicker it took me till i was in my
probably 40s to really understand that
your thoughts lie to you
and your thoughts
will steer you down the road like
when your thoughts have you ever
you're listening have you ever
like thought a girlfriend did something
wrong and all of a sudden you're all
fired up like how could she do this or a
boyfriend respect you emotionally
respond then you get there and you find
it was all it didn't even happen right
or like i can't believe my buddies went
to the movie and they didn't invite me
and you realize they left you a voice
memo like things can happen to fires up
that are just our perception of the
situation or insecurities that are
bubbling up or whatever it is i mean
think about when i when i say that is
like think of thoughts right
two
identical situations there's a car
accident two people are involved one
circumstance someone gets out and
screams their head oh how can you do
this i'm going to be late my insurance
is going to go up what are you stupid
how can you do this you like that you
see it yeah then you see like are you
blind right that's one same circumstance
right someone else does it and gets out
and says they say i'm sorry oh no big
deal it's cars it's metal we have
insurance nobody's hurt who cares hey
can i buy you a coffee you look a little
shaken up yeah right so when someone
says no when somebody says get real or
this is what actually happened nothing
is what actually happened what happened
is this the sich is the perception of a
situation now i know you probably heard
that a million times but maybe this is
the first time you actually think about
it
your situation right now is being held
back
or
being fueled simply but by what you
think you have right and when you change
that story you change your life like
and one of the ways that i think is
really important is if you feel like you
can't start your own company because you
don't have money and you're not smart
enough then go google john paul digiorio
and look at his story who started
videotaping him on the show what's that
we actually interviewed i love john paul
yeah right go google richard branson
tony robbins me everybody i know
everybody i was with this weekend none
of them started with money none of them
were like hey here's a hundred grand go
start your business right blueprint on
how to do it yeah three quarters of
people were with this weekend didn't go
to college like not that you find
someone who you say i can't do i don't
have a supportive spouse find someone
who didn't have a supporter's house and
they did it anyway and prove that the
story that your subconscious has
developed to protect yourself
like literally when it pops up that that
limiting belief that doubt talk that
that inner villain says it's the wrong
time wrong president wrong economy just
prove it wrong and call it a liar and
start figuring a way to empower that and
tony robbins i go to i fly down the
floor he says come down spend a couple
days with me i go down with him and his
amazing wife sage we're at his house and
tony looks at me and goes brother
all i've heard you talk about is
what could go wrong and
who you don't want to be
you can't create a bigger future and
we're going to get into that next
without
this one thing i i got to ask you this
and i remember he got like this close to
my face and he said to me
who do you want to become in your 50s
i've heard it a million times i've read
it in books but that i look at you right
now i don't care if you're in your 20s
30s 40s 50s 60s 70s who do you want to
become in your next generation
who not what are you going to accomplish
how much money you're going to have who
do you want to become
man at that moment it hit me i want to
become a
man who admitted his mistakes and
attracts the most amazing woman in his
life and i want to be a man that's
obsessively in love with one woman i
want to be the father that my kids look
at and go
my dad went through a tough time divorce
was tough business wasn't easy guy my
dad lived in a trailer park when he was
a kid didn't have an education past
ninth grade
but my dad accomplished he's an amazing
father he's an amazing husband to his
wife he's an amazing leader he's an
amazing
role model for people like that's who i
want to become and when i started
thinking about that i don't know about
you man i'm getting goosebumps right now
i start feeling empowered on who i want
to become not what i want to achieve so
for me the momentum is starting right i
was going down that's why this loop i
was going down who did i not want to
become and going down all of a sudden
you could start spinning
this momentum right did you ever like go
behind a boat or see something behind a
boat on a tube when they when they
whipped the boat around that tube's like
goes so fast that's this you see the
problem is so many people get to these
points and the momentum going down
steers them off or throws them off and
then they live life flat they live life
saying i almost made it
if that recession didn't come in 2017 i
would have been fine if kova didn't take
my legs out i would have been fine
if my business didn't go i would have
been if i didn't go through that divorce
i would have been fine
it's because they just bailed on one of
these things it was so painful they
didn't have a process to get through the
loop they bailed on one of them and
that's the person that you talk to
in the uber or you know great people
that say
i almost made it
but
screw butt
we all have that we all have something
we're all different we all have unique
circumstances but the people who make
the difference are the ones that stay in
the game and have a process to get
through the game
and that's why i want to give you this
framework create the not to do list
that's another training we've done but
when you start getting this vision when
you start understanding what your unique
abilities are what could cut you the
biggest check and knowing where you want
to go you're spending the time here with
me when you know that
then it's time for you to make a not
to-do list what are the things you
should not be doing
there's too many all of us are i still
do but i make the list all the time
what are the things that don't serve you
write them down because when you write
down things you shouldn't be doing when
they don't serve that bigger future when
they're not in unique ability when
they're not cutting you a check when
they're not taking you towards your
bigger goal
that should be on your not to-do list
and remember in today's world
there's so many things that you
shouldn't be doing right so when you
make a not to-do list i always write you
can do four things you can eliminate it
ariana huffington is a good friend of
mine she started huffington post in her
60s and she sold it for 300 million
dollars
she said sometimes the best way to
to
get things off your list and they should
be on your not to do list is just quit
them just eliminate them you shouldn't
be doing them anymore just sometimes a
project that you've been working on for
years you're like i'm just not doing
that project cause i'm not excited about
anymore i was obligated but i'm not
obligated anymore obligation without
commitment is a mess remember that
obligation without a commitment is a
mess causes stress sometimes the best
way to do it is quit it eliminate it
stop doing it time opens up next is
delegated do you know you could get
virtual assistants all my top students
are using virtual assistants right now
from the philippines go to upwork.com
you can't believe four or five bucks an
hour and you get somebody for a few
hours a week to do things that you can
never imagine from virtually they can do
everything in today's world with
technology you have your food delivered
your house cleaned uh you know take
notes do your taxes you know do do uh
stuff on the internet they could build
click funnels pages they could make
offers in real estate my students have
virtual assistants doing their real
estate offers uh posting signs all over
craigslist doing ads on facebook it's
crazy four bucks an hour the world has
changed delegate it get a relative a
cousin stop doing the things you
shouldn't be doing or automate it the
cool thing about technology nowadays
there's so many things we do we get to
automate i mean the extreme is i walk in
my house and i can say alexa play uh ed
sheeran radio i feel like listen to that
and i'll listen to it while and i'll go
and i'll look in the cabinet and there's
no paper towels alexa
order paper towels that's all i got to
say next day amazon drops paper towels
off the front door it's insane i didn't
set it up i had someone else my wife or
someone set it up but i'm just saying
the world has changed find out things
that can you can automate that don't
cause a lot of problems
it's not heavy technology i should say
replace it right so you can automate it
you can delegate it you can eliminate it
or you can replace it
you make that not to-do list what are
you doing what are we doing when we and
i'm tying all this together a lot of you
have heard a lot of these but tied
together to unique ability and biggest
check do you see how when you start
doing more of what you're good at that
puts you in flow that gives you
enthusiasm and start saying no to the
stuff that doesn't serve you that
someone else can be doing for a fraction
of it i mean i write i'm terrible my
words are from my mouth but i mean i'm
terrible with spelling and grammar i'm
not going to spend time to get good at
spelling and grammar i could send it to
someone at fiverr or upwork and have
them edit it for pennies in in most
cases pennies why would i do that my
unique ability is giving you the
messages and the words of going out and
learning more of gaining more wisdom so
i can give you the tools so you can
break through that's where i spend my
time that's my unique ability in a
business
a job you lose it right now with covid
with all the things that went sideways
you'd be going i lost i lost i lost but
what if this is the universe god
whatever you believe in saying what you
were doing was not meant for you it was
not allowing you to live into your full
potential you have more to give the
world if you won't do it on your own i'm
going to do it for you you won't close
that door i'm locking it go find
something that fills your heart people
with unsuccessful businesses also take
opinions from the wrong people they take
advice from your parents advice from
your friends
at a picnic advice from people who
pretend they know what they're doing
their co-workers if someone's not
playing the game at the highest level
possible do not listen to them if
someone tried and failed don't listen to
them because they only know how to do it
wrong but people do all these things
they focus their energy they want to
make more money they focus their energy
on the wrong
on the wrong areas they focus on the
products the color they focus on the
logos they focus on the location or what
their website should look like and all
this obsessive stuff that means nothing
at the end of the day they try to create
something that people need and people
don't buy something unless they want it
and then when it's not working or before
they launch they ask an unqualified
person and then you wonder why your
business doesn't work and you feel like
you're stuck at a job or stuck in a
business that's not paying you anything
if you have your own business and you're
working 46 to 80 hours a week and making
less than you can at a job then you just
built yourself a job you don't have your
own business
people want transparency
honesty and authenticity
on the deepest level you could possibly
imagine
i'm encouraging you to change the level
of your transparency i'm encouraging you
not to over plan and try to perfectly
script and be the most authentic version
of you
sharing why you've been there i'm gonna
tell you to share your problems and your
mistakes
at the deepest level you possibly can
people will buy from you and learn from
you when they feel understood what
happens with the holding the checks and
the lamborghinis and all that pieces
it's so
superficial and so shallow people want
to know what happened on the journey to
get to your next level of success how
did you fail and still succeed people
know the difference share the experience
that hurt the most share the experience
that you were once embarrassed of and
watch how people will connect with you
immediately and i'm not talking about
this the sad story and then you leave
them there i'm talking about sharing
that vulnerable moment that the mistake
you made the thing you were embarrassed
about and then show them where you've
come
they immediately will build rapport with
you
so i'm going to encourage you to go one
step further i'm going to encourage you
to share with people the things that you
hid the things that you don't want
anybody to know about the things that
you think people would judge you for for
those are the things that make you real
it doesn't matter what age you are be
authentic be enthusiastic the biggest
podcast i ever had i shared the pain of
going through a divorce last year
and i shared it authentically i shared
my pain i shared that i had anxiety i
shared that i was human and it went
crazy it was something that i was
embarrassed of of going through a
divorce i'm the success guy and i
couldn't make my marriage a success but
i shared it with my heart and it went
nuts and we got tens of thousands of
comments of people saying thank you
share deeper stronger
openly more because if you want to make
an impact let people know how much you
care i want you to start thinking
outside the box i want you to start
thinking if you want to start a business
if you want to scale a current business
or someday maybe you're not even
thinking about now but someday you want
to i want you to think on how you can
out market the competition how you can
do something different than they do how
can you be a relationship marketer not a
transactional marketer how can you build
reciprocity
in the area that you want to specialize
in so this morning i had breakfast with
a friend of mine named lisa she's
awesome she's the top hair stylist in
arizona like literally number one
and
we were talking about expanding her
brand now she's smart as
this girl is amazing and reads every
personal growth book she read my book
before i even was friends with her i
mean unbelievable
but what she's thinking is i need to
expand my brand so i gotta i gotta take
more pictures and get a lot prettier
looking stuff on social media on
instagram especially now that's true
she should
but simultaneously that's not going to
grow your brand in today's world
especially with the algorithms of
instagram and facebook that are just
really set up for spending money to grow
right so the days of going viral uh and
getting millions of followers on
instagram just because you're awesome
are kind of over it happens we're
growing we're growing at a you know
several thousand a week all organically
but it's a lot of work right so
this is what i suggested to her this
morning she's an expert at hair
extensions and she wants the world to
know that there's so many bad ways
there's the mid-level you know too much
hair in the mid i i like and there's a
big bump here or their girls get
extensions and the little clips show if
they leave it on too long their hair
gets brittle all this stuff that i was
learning and i said build reciprocity do
something completely different in the
industry and i'm saying this to her but
now i'm saying it to you what i
suggested to her is something that my
dear friend joe polish did many many
years ago and it's an updated version he
did something called the consumer
awareness guide in the carpet cleaning
industry you think it has nothing to do
all good marketing it doesn't matter
what industry you're in nobody wants to
get their carpets cleaned and that guy
figured out how to get people excited to
do it so
think about that uh
a consumer awareness guide so we're
sitting down talking and i said yes
there's a lot of great people in your
space and they're going to do good
pictures and you could do better
pictures and you could fight on price
and that's what everybody does and she's
not she's one of the most expensive
so i said what about
building reciprocity and building a
relationship with clients and future
clients by just simply helping them
create something cooler like the the
consumer awareness guide for hair
extensions but maybe you you know it's
the seven taboos of getting uh uh uh
hair extensions
in 2018 right
so i said we started going through it i
said what if you just
created this document that shared that
you are the top hair stylist in arizona
so you're an expert you've been doing
extensions you're she specializes in
people's extensions being screwed up and
then she comes and fixes them same with
color right but let's just talk about
the extensions now and she has that
authority so why don't you write a
consumer awareness guide call it
something sexier but inform people on
what to look out for so they can avoid
their hair being screwed up they can
avoid their hair being burned off they
can avoid the puffiness they can avoid
the clips showing so everybody knows you
have extensions and write like the seven
deadly sins of getting the wrong hair
extensions at the same time that she's
educating people she's building
reciprocity she's helping them
what is she doing
she's getting people to look to her as
the authority the expert like whoa what
does lisa say i don't know if i'm gonna
get extensions i should go to the expert
i should go to the person who's the
authority helping other people
know what's right or wrong that's what a
consumer awareness guide can do that's
what a great book does if you don't have
time to write a book create a consumer
awareness guide so if you're in the
fitness world
you might write the seven deadly sins of
the wrong workout if you're in the lose
weight world you might sell the the
seven deadly sins of having sugar-filled
breakfast the like if you are in the
consulting business you're in the
coaching business the the seven deadly
sins of having the wrong life coach real
estate coast health coach workout coach
right so think about
how do you build relationships how do
you build reciprocity and because we
live in a world like hey do something
for me
i'll do something for you
what if we just lived in a world where
i'm going to do a ton for you and i hope
you come back why do you think i do
these podcasts why do i think i created
subscribe to dean.com so you go there
and get discounts and all that cool
stuff because i want to give it out to
the world i'm i'm doing these podcasts
on my time i'm shooting this on my day
off for you
not because i'm expecting you to do
something right now but when you think
about wanting success education or real
estate education or you want to go to
the next level or be part of a
mastermind i hope you go wow dean's been
helping me for years for free his
podcasts are free it goes on social
media every day for free goes on
instagram every day for free he gave
away
350 000 copies of his book if you just
cover shipping and handling right like i
want you to think about that and go wow
and i know his values and i know what he
stands for
if i'm gonna spend money for higher
education i'm gonna go with dean that's
what i hope i'm being transparent i want
my business to grow but i want to touch
more lives right so think about that in
your business of like what can you
instead of marketing on price or
marketing like everybody else what can
you give how can you build reciprocity
give all of you so when it's time for
them to spend money to get the education
to get the product to get the service
you're the first person they think about
the last
year last two years but really last year
i've been going through a divorce and
i've told no one i haven't shared it
publicly a small group of my family and
friends know and it's been the most it
was the most painstaking thing i've ever
experienced in my life now i can go back
through the whole thing on why this
happened there's a million reasons the
cool part is um my ex because we signed
the divorce papers i have this that's
the first time i ever said my ex
my ex and i are dear friends not kind of
friends not fake friends we're true
friends where we're doing a
child-centered divorce the focus is on
our kids you see i'm going to back up
here in a moment and tell you that i
haven't shared with you guys but i went
through about a 90-day
every day filled with anxiety couldn't
sleep at night all because i want to
leave my kids if you guys know me you
watch me you listen to me you know my
kids are the most important thing in my
life
and i love waking up every day i love
having family dinners i love family
meetings on sundays i take them to
baseball practice practice go baseball
games i'm at every dance recital i like
to be there for homework i love to cook
for them i love to play with them i mean
i i love working and growing and i love
my kids and my parents were married and
divorced a bunch of times so the thought
of divorce and ripping the family apart
ripped my soul apart it it opened up
worries and anxieties of things that i
tucked down when i was a kid when my
parents split when i was three and then
married and left married and left nine
marriages between my two parents i had
this inner demon this inner fear that i
tucked down many many years ago and when
the thought was real when a year ago i
knew that divorce was inevitable we
tried a lot of i don't want to say we
tried like oh we gave it a shot we went
to therapy we talked we spent a year
seeing if we could make it work and
unfortunately we couldn't
my my relationship with my ex is this
dear friendship but telling the kids
leaving the kids i can't even tell you
the feeling i experienced my empathy my
compassion my heart goes out for another
group of people that have to deal with
that um i dealt with it as a kid now i
was dealing with it as a parent
the reason i'm sharing that is because
as much as i think i got my together and
i work on my personal growth i work on
success i'm the i feel like in my own
head this is kind of like my own thing
i'm like i'm a
man i'm a boss i take care when stuff
goes sideways i got it if a building was
on fire you want to be standing next to
me because i'll get your ass out the
company's crashing i'll save your
[ __ ] company for you any anybody in
my family has a problem my parents i've
been supporting my parents since i was
in my 20s my parents have problems
emotionally or with friends i'll take
care of it friends come to me i got this
i got you
i love that i love being the guy i love
being able to serve you but all of a
sudden i get hit with something and it
takes my feet out i mean luckily i go i
went down and spent some time with tony
robbins talking to him about it i'm dear
friends with dr daniel eamon i spent a
couple days with him i mean i'm so lucky
that i have access to great people but
still it took my legs out so why am i
taking the time to share this with you
to be so vulnerable to to
let you in on the deepest part of me
is because i don't ever want you to
think that i that my life is perfect i
don't want you to think that
successful people everything's just the
line the the clouds open and the sun
shines and life is perfect no we have to
deal with [ __ ] and i'm not saying you're
worse or better than mine i just want to
be vulnerable to tell you that though it
was the scariest thing in my life hands
down
you might have had some traumatic stuff
as a kid i did as well
some crazy stuff maybe that'll be for
another podcast with thinking my mom was
gonna die and and
father go to jail like crazy stuff that
i could
but none of that compared to this
thought of leaving my kids and it was so
scary it was if you
i mean for me my internal clock was like
i was gonna die that's how i felt so why
do i say that because i was so scared of
it and i wanted to run i wanted to go
back i wanted to just leave it the way
it was i'll stay in an unhappy marriage
both of us should so we'll be there for
the kids i want to make all these
decisions just to leave it the way it is
like the pain was so bad i wanted to put
the cork back on the bottle and the
reason i want to share this with you
today is because that would have been
the worst mistake of my life
i had to face my biggest fear if you
noticed for the last year i've been
talking a lot about your next level of
life lives on your biggest obstacle your
biggest stress your biggest worry i'm
not giving you permission to end a bad
relationship or or just run in the other
direction but face it if you have to fix
it take it to another level get the
right capabilities and your business in
your life if you're worried about your
job and if you quit you'll go broke face
it work hard to get the promotion or or
burn the boats and go start your own
thing i i'm just telling you
with all the work that i do i was an
inch away from going backwards
and i thank god for the great friends i
have i thank god for the influences i
have the books i read the people i know
most most of my information comes from
books and trainings that i've purchased
myself in areas that i don't feel strong
but now let me tell you the other side
i'm in a place now where again my ex and
i are the dearest of friends our kids
come first my kids have been told they
know their mom and dad are divorced
my ex got a new house we got her all set
up in there
and we're both
thriving we're on the other side of our
biggest obstacle we're on the other side
of our biggest pain the other side of
the anxiety the other side of the worry
and i want to share this with you
because it didn't happen overnight i
couldn't fix it immediately i was having
anxiety and i was trying to talk myself
out of it and think myself out of it and
keep myself busy and none of it worked i
had to lean into it i had to face it i
had to look inside i had to sit with it
but i've grown
and i'm another version of me you know i
always felt like the underdog i was
always small in school i was literally
hands down not just kind of the smallest
kid in school i was the smallest kid in
school plus we didn't have any money i
mean i say that it's not like the story
just for my marketing i we truly didn't
have money my mom worked two jobs to
make 90 bucks a week my dad worked in
his collision shop to probably make 25
30 grand a year worked his butt off they
were hard workers they had there was no
correlation between hard work and making
money though it's smart hard work right
but i want to tell you a story when i
was in my 20s i became the new england
championship grass dragger with a
snowmobile that sounds weird i don't
know if it's called it's grass drags you
race on grass five to seven hundred feet
drag racing with a snowmobile you put
these big long paddles uh these spikes
with paddles in the in the um in the
track you you bolt them in you
you change you lighten the machine up
and it's really just this major like i
mean i'd go 100 miles an hour and 500
feet is that crazy or what but here's
the thing
i was absolutely the underdog
because i didn't have any money back
then i mean i had some i was working
hard this is my time in my 20s i'm doing
real estate this is early 20s doing real
estate working on cars every day with my
dad at the collision shop that type of
thing but i didn't have the money
that some of these people had because
when i started getting good and i
started winning more and more
um i was ramping up so i would um
i would go to these meets where it would
be like the new england championship so
there would be i parked the car okay no
hands because i parked the car there'd
be uh people from all over the eastern
part of the united states and all of a
sudden i'd go and there'd be team
articat and team polaris and and team
skadoo big tractor trailers they'd take
their machines off with a forklift
they'd have a crew of 10 people with all
awesome shirts on they're fine to them
and these snowmobiles were sold out so
i don't know if you ever raced
motorcycles or snowmobiles this loud
deep throttle and i would go there with
my pickup truck with my snowmobile on
the back i had all my uh tools and an
old milk crate you know like the the
plastic square milk crate all my tools
stacked up and you have to have ways to
lube the track i had like a handmade way
to lube the track and i had a leaf
blower that would cool down the engine
because you'd race in the fall in the
spring so sometimes the snowmobiles got
hot because they like to run in the cold
weather right they're designed for snow
so i'm telling why am i telling this
story because i was thinking about it
like
you might feel like an underdog and
what's the definition of an underdog
maybe you don't have money to get
started maybe no one in your family
supports you because they think you're
nuts that you want to do your own thing
maybe you live in a country or world a
town a city where people are
discouraging you it doesn't seem like
things are good or maybe you feel like
you're an underdog because you were born
during a bad time or or maybe you had
some really tough things in your past
maybe you're married to someone or
dating someone who is negative and and
tells you what you can't do i don't know
but we all have that little bit of
underdog feeling inside
and most of the time it can squash us it
can keep us small but i want to tell you
i teach my kids for their for softball
and for baseball i teach them that you
win races you win games when no one is
watching and i've been implementing in
that that to them because i want them to
practice like you don't win when you're
on the pitcher's mound and you get the
the glory you don't win i've said this
before but you don't win as a rock star
just when you're up there jamming to 50
000 people you're winning when you're
throwing a hundred balls
in the dark when no one's watching up
against the fence or you're jamming on
the guitar you know till late at night
when no one's watching that you win when
no one's watching well i won new england
state snowmobile championship when no
one was watching you see
i was the underdog these people i ended
up racing when i got to the highest
level and i used to race i had a polaris
650 not that that means anything to you
it was a 1989 polaris 650 snowmobile but
i
that i raced in the 650 class the 700
class and the 800 class and i'd win all
three of them now i didn't have the
money these other guys did i didn't have
them full-time set of mechanics i didn't
have a tractor trailer with separate
engines and new clutches and all this
stuff i just had me and a buddy would
come with me a buddy or two would come
me in a milk crate and my tools in it
but you know what i did
when no one was watching uh being the
underdog i knew i didn't have the money
i couldn't beat them i couldn't out
spend them
i couldn't hire a full-time mechanic
that wasn't my life i had worked all day
with cars and real estate and on
weekends i'd go do that but what i used
to do is i go out in the apple orchard
behind my house when no one was watching
and i perfected
this i don't want to get too technical
but i perfected the clutching because i
couldn't afford just get my motors
redone a lot to get a lot more
horsepower cars go faster with more
horsepower but i worked on the clutching
meaning how fast the snowmobile shift
how high the rpms were when it came out
not that means anything to you but what
i did when no one was watching i'd bring
my milk crate because i was the underdog
it gave me an unfair advantage because i
wanted i didn't want those people with
more money more you know you could think
about in every area of your life right
think about this whatever you're
thinking about i didn't want them
because they had more money to be like
uh what's that guy trying i loved going
in there with my you know my my i pulled
my stomach off the back of my truck and
my tools were messed up and they had all
these people and i'd make it to the
finals and i could see them looking at
i'm like how'd this guy get in the
finals and then i'd kick their ass i
mean i smoked him i won there was a time
where i went 39 races 39 first place in
a row week after week because when no
one was watching i'd go out in this
apple orchard i'd mark out 500 feet and
i bring my buddy out there and i'd go
run i go 90 miles an hour at 500 feet
and i go back and i'd time it and i'd
write it down like the clutching i think
i could let the rpms go up and i i
literally used to have a file that this
doesn't mean anything but think of the
intricacies of this i would have a file
and i'd file the clutching because in
snowmobiles and i got i haven't raced
the snowmobile in 25 years but it's a
centrifugal clutch is what makes it
shift on its own it's not like a manual
shifter it's not automatic like your car
it's a clutch system so inside this
clutch are weights and as it starts
going around circle the revolutions per
minute it throws the clutches it throws
the weights out and it makes it shift so
i figured a way to like change the angle
so they'd flip up quicker or i'd lighten
them down i'd grind a little bit off the
side make them go quicker and i changed
the weights and the clutching i did all
this stuff that i couldn't have because
i couldn't afford the horsepower i
couldn't afford to send my engine out
and spend 10 grand to make it just this
pristine engine so i messed with the
clutching then i took gearing so again
i'm telling you all this for a reason i
took gear i changed the gears we were
racing 500 feet i'd have gears so my
snowmobile would be going as fast as it
possibly could at 500 feet if we were
racing 900 feet they'd blow by me 100
miles an hour but i got all the juice
out of the 500 feet so what's the moral
of the story i didn't have the money i
was the underdog i didn't have what they
had but what i had was a burning desire
deeper than they ever could and that
created in ingenuity right like i found
a way to get the sloan bill to go faster
without the money i played with the
clutches i played with the gears what in
your life can you play with to adjust
the knobs how can you adjust the gears
how can you use your passion your desire
your that underdog feeling instead of
the anchor the wind behind your sail the
biggest lie we've ever been told in the
history of the world or one of them is
that we should get strong or weak at the
hell would that
get amazing at what you're good at
because when you work on the things
you're good at the things that make you
thrive and feel alive your confidence
goes up when your confidence goes up
then everything else starts to get
easier you don't look at things as a
problem you look at things as a
challenge when you walk into the meeting
to ask for the promotion ask for the
raise ask for the partnership you don't
go oh my god will this work maybe i
should be happy to go no i got this
when you think someone is being rude to
you someone doesn't want to be the
partner the the the relationship there's
no support like all of these things that
distract us from the things we really
want the money we want to make the
abundance we want to create the company
we want to create we're letting all
these things uh
ding our inner confidence the thing that
allows us to feel loved and feels feel
worthy feel good enough
we're allowing someone else's cause and
effect to create a new result in our
life
so what if from this point forward every
relationship you had when you see the
forward-facing thing the
taking the hat and throwing in the woods
for my son or the friend stomping her
feet because she didn't get her way
instead of saying what did i do am i
good enough
rather say wow
have empathy of realizing there was a
previous cause to create that effect
then here's the here's the whole point
of this lesson then turn the mirror on
yourself what causes in your life are
allowing you to affect the current is
there a cause of the way your parents
treated you that you're afraid to start
your own business is there a cause
that you got burned in a relationship
and you're not opening your heart to a
new one is there a cause that your dad
treated you like and told you you were
never good enough and the effect is
you're doing a little bit of that with
your kids
start looking at it that way and you'll
have empathy for others and you'll have
acceptance of others and you won't let
them bug you or let you feel a certain
way they won't ding your confidence and
also you'll strengthen the relationships
in your life because believe me you're
going to find crap that's lingering from
your childhood from previous
relationships from your parents that
you're screwing with other people where
you could fix it i remember hearing a
story where this couple
wanted their whole life their their
dream their desire their whole life was
to move to the west coast and get a
house on the ocean well they saved up
their whole life pushing their they were
they were delaying their happiness
delaying their gratification until they
got this house they get this house they
move in it's paradise it's heaven the
first month every night they're watching
the sun go down watching the sunsets
having a glass of wine toasting baby we
made it
fast forward six months this is a true
story at least the person who told me
the story said it was a true story um
six months later the wife was like honey
we have to get blinds put on the west
facing windows it's so annoying every
night when i'm cooking the damn sun is
coming through the windows and it's so
hard to pay attention
wow
their whole life to watch the sunsets
over the ocean became annoying so we
have to watch what we're spending money
on and make sure is that feeding some
significance that we're trying to prove
to someone else we're trying to prove
that we made it we're starting show off
the rolex show off the lamborghini
listen i think everyone if you need to
go through that phase but here's the
same thing i tell my kids and i want to
tell you
figure out what success means to you on
the deepest level possible i went
through the fantasy watch phase of my
life i have hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of watches i don't wear
any right now not that i'd criticize
anyone who does i wear t-shirts all the
time now i have thousand dollar sports
jackets because i went through that
phase but what i'm realizing and i'm
realizing a little bit later in life
that's why i want to get to everybody no
matter what age you are is that the
moments in between
are what where the magic lives so i
asked you what you were spending money
on i want you to make sure you're
investing enough money into you into
your personal growth into the business
you have or into the business you want
to create or into growing yourself so
you could be an entrepreneur if that's
the right word like grow within your
company i don't care where you want to
grow but you need to grow and i want to
make sure you're spending money on
things that give you an roi either an
roi on wisdom an roi and success an roi
on memories an roi on happiness an roi
on health so i'm thinking i i mean what
i was thinking even in my own life and i
want to share with you is you need to
create an audit of where your money is
being spent because here's what i know
i'm so far from cheap i i don't stress
about money i didn't stress about money
spending it for other people especially
when i didn't have any when i was paying
on credit cards to help other people out
i i always had this feeling i know i can
create more now do i worry about it of
course or i have in the past but i
always knew i could create more money
but when i look back i realize how much
money got spent on things that mean
nothing and now i spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on my own education
i go to at least 10 to 12 masterminds
every single year and every time i go oh
my god i'll gain capabilities on how to
go faster on facebook or write a book
quicker or how to market better or how
to invest in new real estate in new
industries or i'll get a tip from a guy
who's an amazing dad or a mom who's in a
great relationship and blow my mind like
i came here to make more money but i got
a tip on how to bond with my daughter
better father daughter bonding this
guy's amazing boom like exponential
growth through learning from other
people if you if someone gives you
advice if you wouldn't replace your life
with theirs they give you advice on how
to make money how to fix your
relationship how to get a promotion but
most of the time people are unqualified
giving us advice the broke friend
telling us how to make money
the unhappy miserable single friend
telling us how to fix our marriage bad
advice is the most costly advice in the
world but i take it one step deeper
you've heard that before but bad advice
to me dings my confidence it's got to go
so if if bad advice dings your
confidence then get to push the people
out that are bringing you down and
making you dim your glow push them out
of your life or if they're really close
in your life find a way to not let their
words affect you unless you'd rather be
them i'm recording this early monday
morning i haven't had a
inch of food an ounce of food since
saturday
because i'm doing a procedure i'm doing
a
colonoscopy i turn 50 this year i got to
get it done i've been putting it off and
i want to share that with you as crazy
as that sounds is because that's life is
doing the things we don't want to do and
finding a way to empower and power
through them to get to the other side so
let me just give you a little background
not that you give a crap about this
but my grandfather and a couple of my
uncles died of colon cancer so every
five years i go get a colonoscopy
i went five years ago they found some
stuff they said just do it again so i'm
going i'm fine all that but why am i
sharing this because i love to eat i've
never fasted in my entire life i'm
skinny and i have to eat all day every
day
just to maintain this a massive frame of
mind no this 150 pounds of i've been 150
pounds since right out of high school i
have to eat a lot that's just the way
i'm genetically made up
not eating a meal drives me crazy
nevertheless two days and nothing but
water
and then i made my kids a massive meal
yes i took them for i took them for ice
cream last night because sunday's our
cheat day i got up this morning made an
amazing meal and nothing so you're
saying okay dean who really cares about
your colonoscopy and you're hungry big
deal
but here's how i like to approach
everything in life and i think it's
served me really well when it comes to
success
is there are so many things we don't
like to do i
i put this off for a little bit i should
have done it about six months ago but
then i just thought
what are the benefits of me getting this
done well peace of mind massive peace of
mind to know that i got nothing bugging
me because i want to live to be a
hundred to be here for my kids and my
grandchildren
knowing it's out of the way
knowing a clean build bill of health i
mean think about this right i love that
indian proverb that says a man who has
his health has a thousand wishes a man
who has none
has just but one
or has but just one i'm a little
delirious right now without food but
anyway
the reason i'm sharing this today
because i think this should be your
wake-up call i think this podcast that
you're listening to right now you're
listening to her for me for a reason i i
i kind of hit the same points over and
over in different ways because that i
mean if you if you like a good song how
many times do you listen to it 100 times
200 times 500 times well if there's a
message that can empower your life
shouldn't you listen to it over and over
until you finally freaking do it
i want you to think about today this
colonoscopy i i guess i got to say the
pun it's a real pain in the ass from the
food i gotta go get to put to sleep
today i can't drive myself it's such a
pain in the ass
starting your business is a pain in the
ass
obsessing on marketing more than just
your product sometimes a pain in the ass
convincing your spouse your friends your
family your loved ones your parents
your significant other that you're going
to maybe phase out your job and
scale up your business or you want to
start that thing that fills your heart
and go with your passion you want to
start music an online career you want to
start selling stuff on amazon start real
estate all that can sound so scary to
other people so then you dim your glow
you turn your brightness down to match
everybody else because it's going to be
a pain listen
everything in life starts as an as
something
that's a struggle a struggle or annoying
or hard or frustrating or scary
but if you just settle then you just
leave your life the way it is i mean if
your life was absolutely perfect you'd
be listening something different than my
podcast you want another level of life
and i'm here to tell you
it's just like this damn colonoscopy i
don't want to do it but i want the
results it's going to give me i i shared
with you guys a message or a podcast
about going to the gym and about
focusing on after now i want you to talk
about something even more serious
is what in your life are you
procrastinating on what if this podcast
was your wake-up call to be maybe the
first time you've heard it and actually
implemented it that you're going to
identify the things that you're hiding
from the things that you're tucking down
the things that you pretend you're too
busy to do the things you're
procrastinating at and turn your ship
towards that what if it's time to say
enough is enough i deserve a next level
of life i deserve more
that's why i mean as simple as this
little colonoscopy thing is i don't want
to do it but i want the end result so
i'm willing to sacrifice a little to
benefit a lot what are you avoiding the
sacrifice on it's time to sacrifice and
it's only little
listen
success is so awesome when you're there
because not many people are willing to
go through the struggle to get there
there was something i shared with
russell brunson he's the owner of
clickfunnels great dude
about
about comedians it's a simple little
analogy and i want you to think about it
because he thought it was such a great
idea i think he went and did a podcast
on it too so i'm like well if he took my
idea and did a podcast i need to share
it with my peeps so here it goes
i told him
how you get good at being on stage now
this could be anything you do in your
life i just want you to think through
this because this is how you write a
book this is how you go on stage this is
how you create the best version of you i
use the analogy of a comedian now a
comedian could be funny as heck but the
first week he writes his skit he's not
going to be in madison square garden
with 50 000 people
but what comedians do
is a comedian will go to all the little
comedy clubs around the country and rate
let's rate a joke from one to ten right
you do a little skit joke what are they
three to five ten minutes long and when
you're done or in the middle of it you
could have people going haha that was
cool or laughing hard or crying or
crying and falling on the floor think
about you know those jokes
i remember being a kid listening to
eddie murphy and my god it was so foul
compared to anything i'd ever heard but
it was so funny
i was literally on the floor laughing so
hard i couldn't catch my breath and it
seemed like i was i was doing that for
like an hour and a half straight so how
does that happen because if you go and
you practice enough if you put the time
in and you go to all the little uh dive
places the little comedy places that see
40 to 200 people
every time you tell a joke that gets a
ah that was funny you throw that one
away and every time you get a joke
that
puts them on the floor in tears laughing
where they can't breathe that sticks and
if you do enough practice if you go to
enough of the small places eventually
what will you have you'll have nothing
but good jokes because you throw out the
good ones and keep testing new material
so when people say dean how are you so
good on stage and how do you know what
to write in your book because i've been
on stage
teaching in front of people for almost
10 years at least once a month and
sometimes it's 200 people sometimes it's
18 000 people and i know when i share
something that impacts your life your
personal growth your personal
development your success
the ability to make more money or have
more happiness or joy i know if i have
the audience that are like ah that was
cool or an audience like wow that was
good or an audience where they're coming
out of their skin where their eyes are
popping out of their head where they're
writing in their journal faster they can
move i know that's my funny joke
that's not just a funny joke that's the
fall on the floor so how does that
relate to you
think about everything you do in life we
don't know how to get better until we
uh you know show our grit until we
hustle until we work hard there's so
many different words people it's a it's
a trendy thing to say hustle or have
grit or work your ass off whatever it is
you want to uh say
but if you're just working hard you
could be running on a treadmill and
treadmill so what is it that you do in
your life is it real estate is it amazon
do you have a brick and mortar building
a retail business do you have a job for
somebody right now but you know there's
more
where can you practice more where can
you be observant to look for the eyes
popping out of their head you made an
impact the jokes that made them laugh
the things that you do that move the
needle the things that make your
business easier make your clients
happier make your co-workers feel alive
make your boss if that's what you're
doing right now be like wow that's
awesome look for more of those and guess
what i'm going to say something so
brilliant right now do more of that and
do less of the things that don't make
the jokes that don't make the people
smile i'm using that silly analogy and
that's why millionaire success habits is
such an amazing book i practiced that
stuff that wasn't just something i
dreamed up overnight it was something i
was in my life for the last 20 30 years
but i wanted to share it in a way to
make sure that when people read it they
were engaged they listened they wanted
it so i want you to think about that in
your life
where can you practice
where can you
take the good
and
grow it fuel it make it better and take
what's not working and throw it away
sometimes have a breakthrough we have to
break something it's what's called
creative destruction what do you have to
throw away in your life and what do you
have to focus on i think
so many people are so used to being
different people in different
circumstances that maybe we don't
consider it lying but are we doing uh a
brutal transparency i guess as we are
brutal honesty are we because i know my
life went to another level when i just
became honest i share pretty openly
especially on these podcasts that in my
business life i was so transparent
transparent with my employees my team
members
uh my customers my clients my marketing
my training is just i just exude
transparency and i want to get better at
it
continually i want to be authentic at
the deepest level possible i think
that's the connection that i think
that's the reason these podcasts are
growing so fast instagram's growing so
fast i don't like the hype i just like
real but i have to tell you in my
personal life i wasn't that transparent
i my marriage even though i love being a
dad more than anything in the world even
though
my act now ex is still a great friend
and a wonderful human being
our relationship hasn't been good in
over five years
and i hid that i didn't talk about it uh
i did so many things to avoid it and not
be brutally honest because when i when i
went towards being brutally honest there
was pain so i'd back off and it seemed
easier to kind of pretend to live a lie
to to tuck it into a compartment and put
a lock on it
and i was wrong
and i look at that with my businesses
and in your life if you are
holding back a secret if you have a
people in your life that you wish you
could be transparent with wish you could
tell them what's on your mind but you
don't you know that's okay if you if
you're around a friend a co-worker
someone who works with you a partner
and when they leave you talk bad about
them when they're not there those things
aren't hurting the universe they're
hurting you
flow state what does that mean okay so i
was in flow state yesterday and in a
four hour period
i would bet to say i got more done in
those four hours
than i did in the previous four or five
days
and what flow state does to me is
compress time it's it's you can get
hours and hours you can get 15 hours
worth of work done
in literally an hour it seems impossible
but it's not and every successful person
i know gets in the flow state so what is
flow state to me
that's a time when you're living
harmonious with the universe with god
with with your bigger future and it's
your your
your talents are flowing through you
it's when you look at the clock and four
hours go by and it seems like four
minutes it's not when you're looking and
going ah another hour to lunch you look
and go holy there's only an hour left
until lunch i wanna i'm not quitting i'm
gonna eat it i'm gonna call i'm gonna
call and have food delivered it's when
you know you're making an impact that's
moving the needle in your life
rather than just busy work that's lit
making you continue to run on a
treadmill you could put the treadmill on
one or you could put the treadmill on 12
it doesn't matter how fast your legs are
moving you still are in the same place
so if you feel like you're in the same
place even though you're going faster
then i want you to think about flow
state now
flow state for me
is first off it's working on the things
that move the needle you really need to
differentiate that in your life you
might be busy if you're listening to me
i bet you're a baller you are a mover
you're a shaker you're a hustler you got
grit all the common new buzzwords that
people are using that's great but if you
have grit and you're a hustler and
you're working on the wrong things then
you're kind of white knuckling you're
you're forcing yourself and you're not
moving the needle you're not going
anywhere or
sometimes you might have had a busy day
and you come home and want to work on
your own business and you white knuckle
go i need to do this i i feel bad i'm
not working more on my own business or
my own dreams or the promotion i want
and you kind of force it and then the
needle doesn't move and you're like ah
it's like self-fulfilling like it's
really not helping maybe i should stick
in this life that i really don't like no
you shouldn't you need to switch
everything up a little bit that's why
you're here that's why you're gaining
the millionaire's success habits again i
i didn't i didn't invent this stuff i've
just just been through it all and i get
to share from the other side of success
and failure so here's what i want to
share
i want you to think about creating first
off the atmosphere for the
for the perfect working environment now
i don't know if
you like working in a busy coffee shop
where people are coming in you got your
earbuds on you like the energy i like
that kind of stuff i like going to the
hotels in phoenix i just drove by the
royal palms that's a place i go and work
all the time
it's got the right music
the sound is the the atmosphere is great
the temperature is always perfect
there's a waitress that comes and brings
me my green tea and brings me snacks and
i'll sit there with earbuds and work for
hours i can get them flow state there i
can also get in flow state um
when i'm
literally in the busiest place possible
like a coffee shop with lots of busy
people i like the energy my buddy joe
polish likes to go to libraries where
there's no one and it's quiet but that
helps them get the flow state so for me
atmosphere i love when there's kind of
like spa music playing
i love making sure i got a kombucha and
a green tea and a water and healthy
snacks that i don't have to move i love
physically looking at some i like
looking at camelback mountain that i'm
driving by right now i like looking at a
pool or the mountains or just something
that stimulates if i get in those that
helps the atmosphere secondly other
things i do if i'm if i feel i'm getting
in the flow state to work on something
that's going to move the needle i will
also
um i will shut off my phone i will tell
everybody i'm checking out i will answer
emails i won't answer i won't go on
social media i won't record a video for
you guys if that's not what the part of
my flow state is i eliminate all other
distractions i write down the one to
three things that i want to accomplish
while i'm in this flow state and i set
myself up for fail or for success
because in most days the complete
opposite is we set ourselves up for
failure we want to get more done we want
to accomplish we want to start the new
business write the business plan get the
marketing done uh get the real estate
deal done make the offer but we set up
so many distractions we're trying to do
it while we're juggling kids or we're
trying to get homework done or or our
busy work done for our our regular nine
to five job and we set ourselves up for
failure so
this is a little call to action i
stopped so now i can look at the camera
there's a little call to action for you
guys do you remember a time in your life
that
you got so much done in a short period
of time could have been yesterday last
month last year you got so much done and
you felt amazing when you're done you
felt that sense of accomplishment
those are flow states i didn't name it i
think there's a book flow state or i i
got it from somebody else but i know
when i'm in it and yesterday i literally
compressed time and i accomplished so
much i got done i was like holy crap
look what i got done so i'm going to
encourage you guys to decide what's busy
work and what moves the needle make a
list of needle movers
then pick one or two only and then find
the place that satisfies you i yesterday
i was at my house there was no one home
i put the music all through the house
like spa music i got all my drinks i got
my snacks i put on the most comfortable
clothes i sat facing the mountain where
i live i just lined up everything and i
sat there and whoa magic happened what's
your atmosphere then what are your
thoughts shut off your phone tell
everybody you can't even if it's for an
hour and then immerse yourself in your
goals start thinking about what your
life is going to be like when you get to
your next level get yourself in a space
of abundance get yourself in a space of
gratitude and then attack the one or two
things that move the needle and don't
focus on anything else don't be
distracted don't check email don't check
facebook don't check instagram don't
check how many likes you got stay in
that space get into flow state and watch
the needle move with your
accomplishments stop running on a
treadmill be a ladder entrepreneur
climbing to your next level there is no
faster quicker better or easier way to
gain knowledge than surrounding yourself
with people where everybody's getting
smarter where everybody has a desire to
go to the next level where everyone
has the same
values as you people who want to go to
the same level as you and
nothing could be better but here's the
cool part when i do a mastermind with
russell brunson and brendan bouchard and
lewis howes and trent shelton and so
many incredible people uh tom bilyeu and
and other great great greats
your head just spins because every time
you bring something up they have
something they've experienced that's the
power of a mastermind i don't mean to
digress here but i just want to remind
you if you surround yourself with small
people you'll end up dimming your glow
if you surround yourself with people who
inspire you you'll go to the next level
we all have to pay success tax everybody
wants to be successful everybody wants
to make more money but who's willing to
pay the price of it who's willing to
realize that we have to go through this
to get to the glory people who think
there's the overnight money machines or
you can get rich by inventing something
or the other people got lucky none of
that exists once an
outlier people get lucky what would just
be the recipe or a formula or your
initial advice you would give me to
having just a more fulfilled business a
more fulfilled life a more fulfilled
spirit and existence what would be just
your i mean there's a million things you
could say but if you could give them
something to start with what would it be
um i would say and i might have covered
some of it is really know where you want
to steer your ship like what happens is
i think
we become somebody for our parents when
we're young and then we might become
someone for a relationship we're in and
we come become someone for a boss that
we have or a co-worker or or a partner
or our employees and then we become
someone if you go to church on sunday
and then you become somebody every once
in a while you sneak out to the club and
then you're someone there and we become
all these people that i think what
happens is inside we knew we had this
destination of what we wanted but it
gets diluted by all these things all
these realities like we should cover the
mortgage we should have the money so the
kids can go to college or i should not
go like we have all these things and we
forget who we are what i would say is
spend some time on remembering who you
really are and what you really want and
start saying no to all that
that doesn't point you in that direction
the only reason you're not going where
you want to go is because you're
fragmented it's like fuzzy targets don't
get hit you need a crystal clear target
and i would say just spend time pretend
it's a year from now or five years from
now and you're living the life that you
wanted maybe the life when you were
younger the life before all the cl the
clutter
and find what that is and find a way to
obsess on it and find a way to stop
doing all the other i mean i keep
getting simpler and simpler i start i've
been dressed i got like 20 of these
t-shirts yeah i got hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of watch i
stopped work like i'm finding myself
getting simpler and simpler because i
know where i want to go and nothing else
really matters anymore now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through that's what the science says and
that is not good enough believe nation
we need to do better when you actually
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do this week you have a 91 chance of
following through and when you publicly
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment below on this video it jumps
even higher so i want that for you i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week so i can
celebrate with you when i was young i'm
talking 10 years old
we didn't have any money i lived with my
dad maybe i was probably 11 or 12. look
at my dad we didn't have any money but
all my friends were racing bmx that's
when bmx was huge um maybe it's still
big but that's when it first came out
was exciting
and my friends were getting really nice
bikes i couldn't afford any of those in
fact i fell in love with a bike called
the hutch
there was diamondback and hutch they
were the two best brands back then like
people would buy a mongoose it was like
a lead balloon i mean you couldn't even
pick up a mongoose at the time but these
hutch this hutch bike was all alloy or
whatever kind of metal it was that was
so light and it was amazing so not only
did people get a hut so i'm going and
i'm watching the bmx uh the
bicycle motocross i'm watching the races
and man these kids are flying and
i had a big old heavy bike and i wanted
a hutch i wanted a bike that you could
lift up with one finger but man i wasn't
even close to the money plus i'm going
to school plus i have homework plus my
dad made me do all the chores i had to
do right
so then i figured out how do i get the
money to buy a hutch now of course my
dad my grandmother i live with my dad
and some of my grandmother
they supported me but they didn't have
the money so i asked my grandmother if i
could clean out the garage and clean out
the basement anything i found that she
didn't want could i sell it at a garage
sale now this is summer vacation right
so get into summer vacation and i find
all kinds of stuff that she's like oh i
haven't used that for years i don't want
that i'd throw that out anyway and then
i asked my grandmother if i could do
that in her friend's garages and
basement so i went to her friend evelyn
oh my god i found so much great stuff so
i went to three different places i
accumulated all this stuff and i did a
garage sale every weekend on the front
yard of my grandmother's house i'd walk
like a half a mile to the main highway
main highway for a little town i'd i'd
pound in a sign yard sale and i sat
there and i learned how to sell because
people would come there'd be five bucks
on something i give you two like i don't
want two five's better but how about
four how about three 350. so i'm
negotiating week after week so i use
about four weeks and i make like 250
maybe 300 bucks my dad reminded me of
this story but i remember it was a lot
i'd say like a gazillion dollars but
guess what a hutch bike at the time just
the frame was like 400 bucks then you
had to buy the alloy wheels i wanted the
skinny ones if you know anything about
it was just i wanted the skinny wheels
then i wanted shimano shimano pedals and
i wanted the better ball bearings and i
wanted this cool little uno seat i think
it was called the uni uni seat or uno
seat or whatever it's a cool little
plastic seat i mean this thing was going
to be so light
and
250 or 300 bucks wasn't enough i'm like
wow so now i'm heading back to school my
dad at the time
owns a collision shop but he also used
to buy he'd go to uh
uh auctions where if you got a car
accident and your car was wrecked and it
was totaled or just stolen recovery it
would go to these uh auctions that my
dad would go to and he'd buy a car that
was wrecked but not two wrecked and fix
it up and he'd sell it
so i said to my dad hey can i buy a car
can i buy a car for 250 bucks and then
i'll fix it on my time and i'll pay you
for literally i said i'll fix it on my
time my dad's like yeah you'll pay if
you do that you got to pay for all the
expenses all the parts yourself so i'm
like cool
so now i'm back in school i give my dad
the 250 300 bucks and he goes and buys a
mercury capri now i'd love to say the
day the year but it wasn't even the 80s
it was probably like a late 70s car um
now it's probably an 80s i don't know
late 70s 80s
and it was a capri and i had already
been working with my dad since i was a
little kid working on cars so i knew
cars and he didn't help me much at all
he even said that he was i i let you
struggle and gotta i learned that
parenting style for my dad i wanna i
hope i'm doing a good enough job with my
kids because my dad didn't have the
money he didn't have the time he had a
hustle so he's like you want to wreck
i'll buy it for you but you're paying
all the fees and you got to work on it
so every day i could after school now
i'm still going to school still doing my
homework still doing my chores right
install my regular gig
but every day after school that i could
i'd go work on this capri and i remember
as a first time i wrecked my knuckles so
bad trying to get a bolt off that i
couldn't it slipped and it scraped on
the other ones i'd go to school my hands
greasy and knuckles beat up but i worked
on that i probably could have been done
in a week and it probably took me three
months and when i got to the painting
part i remember i paid the guy that
worked for my dad to come in on a
weekend and paint it because i didn't
know how to paint back
then long story short i get the car done
i sell it
and i profited 900 bucks so i took 250
rolled it over into a wrecked car redid
the car and i made 900
and i went and bought
my hutch bike i bought the pedals i
bought the ball bearings i bought these
cool little alloy wheels that were
really thin i bought the thin little
tires i bought the uni seat i bought
these cool handlebars i even bought some
some gear to work out in
and i got my bike now was i ever good at
racing bmx hell no i sucked i was a
little i'd go week after week and get my
ass kicked i got think i think i got two
trophies and probably a whole two
seasons but i loved it and i wanted to
go every single week and i
i loved this bike so much because i
earned every ounce of that bike every
inch of that bike i fought for i paid
for it but how does that relate to you
because in life we think there's these
magical ways these quick ways these
shortcuts to wealth we think there's
these shortcuts to get the things that
we want our our new hutch it might be
your house might be the car it might be
freedom but we want the shortcuts listen
at a at a young age i was going to
school that was my day job i still had
to do it i did homework i did my chores
all my responsibilities i still had to
do while simultaneously every moment i
could i squeezed into
garage sale and then um and then working
on this car there's no magic money
machine you still got to do the yard
sale while you do your homework you
still got to fix the car this is
metaphorically while you're doing your
chores and going to school but the end
result is i got what i wanted with a
little bit of extra hustle but that
momentum carried my whole life when i
was in the collision business i worked
on my real estate business but i had to
go work on cars every day and finally
got real estate making money and then
i'm in the real estate business i want
to teach others so i was still working
on real estate every day but i'd work at
night creating courses and programs and
then when i was doing i wanted to go to
live events i still worked on course and
programs while i worked on my live event
business i still had to hustle i still
had to find enthusiasm i still had to be
excited i still had to get things done
and i still had to pay the bills
going to school
doing homework doing chores is the same
as working in a collision shop while i'm
working in my dream of real estate
working on my dream of
impacting other people while i'm still
working on real estate if you want some
amazing motivation from ed mylett check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i can't tell you
why i'm this way but i do believe it was
baseball i never took it personally when
a coach said you're dropping your
shoulder in other words because of
athletics when i said spread your right
leg out your legs are too close together
i never thought i suck i can't hit